is that what you're talking about what
do you mean drip you don't know how many
people would pay for that experience
smell good small connor's jeans
get the [ __ ] out of my face man all
these jeans
hey guys welcome to another episode of
trash taste podcast i'm your boy i'm not
your boy i am the boy with the boys
[ __ ] stumble through that's the worst
intro you've ever done no no
your mind just like starting up as
you're staying that sentence yeah like
i'm like i'm like you know those really
old lawn mowers your dad had we have to
do
like five times until it finally gets
started that's my brain right now so how
are you guys weeks man i just had an
absolute [ __ ] ordeal this morning
what
yeah so okay so
this is like [ __ ] what now like
volume eight of gaijin versus japanese
bank right i think i think we're like at
that volume now
the bank strikes back
and uh i mean like to me like now like
going to a japanese bank is kind of like
going to the dentist now because like i
do anything i can to put it off i like
my dentist actually i really i mean it's
been great here
the bank's way far worse i would rather
have like an
anal rectal cavity whatever that is
opposed to going to the bank an anal
rectal cavity
honestly i agree because like i've been
putting off going to the bank for ages
right because i've needed to send money
abroad to back home okay uh because
right now i'm helping my parents pay for
the mortgage of their house so they can
retire and have a nice comfy
sun
right there
just just being a good asian son as you
do um so i mean i've been doing this for
like
basically since i started youtube but
since i moved to japan obviously a lot
most of my money is now in my japanese
bank account and i've known for a while
that i've needed that i was going to
need to transfer money into my british
bank account
i was just dreading this right as you as
you do with any japanese bank experience
um what i didn't realize was that i was
gonna have like the biggest ordeal i've
had yet in the japanese bank
um so i mean like so i'm just like okay
i booked the appointments because you
can you can't do anything online as
we've said
on call god forbid you can yeah be in
the 21st century yeah right yeah so uh i
turn up as usual and uh normally when we
turn up to the bank uh they normally
have one guy who works there that uh
acts as an interpreter because he speaks
english and japanese right
um so he wasn't there today
so they just let you do the appointment
did they know you wrote yeah yeah they
knew it was me they knew so so you know
the guy they weren't going to be like uh
god thought yeah
so so it was the same woman that uh
handles our accounts but the interpreter
the guy who speaks english wasn't there
this time okay so i'm just like okay
this is gonna this is gonna like
this is gonna put my nihongo josu to the
test right this is gonna this is gonna
stretch it to the [ __ ] limits right
because
because uh i mean thankfully i i have
been you know practicing as much as i
can especially my listening skills yeah
but uh this is gonna this was gonna
stretch it to the limits um so bank hard
mode yeah this is this this was bank
like [ __ ] doom impossible mode or
whatever
so um so we start we start the process
and uh we take it we take inventory and
i bring all my usual stuff right
uh i've got my hanko got my bank book
got my bank card got everything fully
prepped yeah fully prepped i'm like i'm
experienced i'm a i'm a [ __ ] japanese
bank of war veteran i know what the [ __ ]
i need to do at japanese banks right so
i'm just like i know what happened
battlefield
some like rates um
so we start the process i'm like can i
transfer money to my british bank
account please or transfer money
overseas and she starts explaining to me
the process and i'm like [ __ ] out
okay i understand like
70 of what you're saying so i'm like i'm
like great i'm following i'm following
what she's saying i'm like you know what
maybe maybe this maybe this will be a
smooth process so
so i put in my name put in put in um put
in
uh my address and everything i need to
do
um and then we get to the actual
transfer part of it okay the actual
transferring money to an overseas bank
and so uh she asks me
uh about the bank and i say oh it's a
british bank it's barclays um it's my
account
um and then she says uh and
here's here's where here's where my
japanese got tested she said something
right and i heard i heard transfer
and i heard purpose yeah and i heard a
connection right okay so in my mind
stitch it all together you know because
because that's how you do it that's how
you do it so i heard those words so i
stick i stitched the meaning of the word
to be what was the purpose of the
transfer right right because that's
that's that's that's naturally what i
assumed so i was like oh great i'm the
purpose of my transfer nigeria
yeah
so i try to explain in the most broken
japanese like and the purpose of my
transfer is just to transfer money to
myself in england yeah i was i was like
british bank account in england my
british bank account in england
transferring money to that yeah and and
she was like no no no and she re and she
re-explains and she re-explains there
and now i'm just like
okay so how do i explain to her that i'm
going to be paying a mortgage for my
parents in england and i'm just like
[ __ ] out okay this is this is this i
don't know i you know i struggled to
spell mortgage in english yeah yeah i'm
just like i guess i'm just like i was
like wait mortgage has a team
uh for the purpose of my parents i'm
paying for their health paying for the
house right and she's like no no no no
and and
and and then we we we just like try to
brokenly communicate to each other and
then she just and then she whips up the
google translate and i'm just like why
don't you whip this out and i'm just
like okay here we go here we go and then
uh she she googled translates it and
she's she's just like and
the translation is
do you have any evidence that you have a
connection to the purpose uh to the
person you're transferring to for the
purpose of this transfer and i'm just
like
what
it's it's me it's literally
it's literally
are we it's me
it's it's me are we like
is this a [ __ ] circus we're running
here like what's going on like how how
can i prove that i have a connection to
myself right so it's like it's like if i
were you i would have been like so how
many [ __ ] got many tacos do
the thing that i was dreading about
japan is that they just nothing's ever
good enough no no no no no yes like no
because because i want to see a passport
of the other youth yeah because because
to a japanese person
sending money to yourself overseas is
just a concept that they don't
understand it's like
why yeah so so the first thing i say was
like uh i mean my names are identical
isn't that enough proof and she was like
no no it's because it's because in
japanese bank uh your first name comes
second and your cert and your surname
comes first so it's manitoba
yeah and then in my british bank gun
barclays is guards manny tapas and
because the names don't match they they
obviously
they obviously assume i'm like a dual
citizen like i'm [ __ ] jason bourne
with five different identities
wait which one no it's actually a
russian guy
so i'm just like what do i need and she
was like uh i don't know i'm just like
and she was just like um i don't know do
you have any bills and i'm like i don't
have any bills because i live in japan
now
well like a bank statement do yeah and
she was just like yeah sure a bank
statement will do and i'm just like
huh do i have to print it out and she
says yes it has to be printed out and
scanned to us i'm just like
well [ __ ] because obviously thanks can i
borrow yours
thankfully with british banks i could
access my statements very conveniently
on my
electronic device and i'm just like okay
how can okay this is where my
engineering problem skills like come in
because i first first think i asked her
like how much like
well can i go to the company to print
off my uh to print off my statement
right and she says sure uh how much time
would that take and i asked how much
time is this appointment book for and
she says i have an hour
all right and the appointments book for
an hour so i have an hour yeah time slot
because i am not [ __ ] going i am not
coming back to the bank just for the
purpose of this transfer yeah and i'm
not missing out on this appointment so
i'm like [ __ ] i'm doing this right
now and and i'm just like oh i'll be
right back i'm going to go to the
combini i'm going to print out my stuff
um print out what i could have showed
you digitally yeah yeah i could have
just done this i could have sent it to
you
exactly so do you have a fax you can fax
it to us so i rush off to the company
and then i realized that
um
so there's so every company has a
printer right and there's only a few
ways to connect to that printer oh yeah
one way
i know you see where i'm going this one
way is via phone and the other way is
via usb stick yeah so i was just like
okay great maybe i got on my phone so
i'll just connect via my phone no so um
i you you think you will yeah
so that that that's me was like my first
my first option to problem solve this
[ __ ] issue that shouldn't be an issue
yeah right so i try to download the app
to connect to the printer um the app's
not available internationally of course
i have uh i have i'm uh my google play
store is still linked to my uk account
luckily luckily that wasn't too big of
an issue because i have a japanese
account as well for this exact purpose
of downloading japanese apps right um so
obviously um i download the app and
everything is in japanese yeah and
obviously my nihongo is not josie enough
to figure out japanese
yeah my money hunger was not good enough
to figure out this app yeah so what i
did is i have a second phone right and
this translator and this second phone is
my my uk phone so i i have like this old
uk phone it's an iphone 5 which is like
my my phone before i upgraded to this
new phone now yeah um which is the only
purpose for that phone is just so i have
a uk sim card so i can phone home or if
any uk people want to phone me so i'm
[ __ ] like i'm [ __ ] on my phone
with another phone googly google
translating my phone with another phone
i've done that
i'm just looking like a [ __ ] clown in
the community being like
so i'm there for about 4 10 15 minutes
trying to get this phone to connect to
the printer yeah it just does not want
to go [ __ ] i don't know what is going
on with the app i don't even think it
was the language i just think it was the
app i've tried i've tried using that app
and i tried for like an hour it just
doesn't connect this is why i just
always carry around the usb stick yeah
right yeah yeah the same thing you never
know when you're in the printer yeah so
so i'm like [ __ ] this isn't gonna work
okay i i i've 15 minutes have passed the
time is ticking i've only got like i've
at this point i've only got half an hour
left of the appointment and i also still
need to fill out the rest of the form so
i've got another 15 minutes the most i'm
just like okay i need to find another
way thankfully i remember i bought my
laptop with me great so i could and i
have a usb stick as well in my bag so
i'm just like great um i just need
internet so unfortunately with japanese
sims you can't tether internet no so
it's like it's like an option you have
to pay for yeah exactly exactly so i'm
just like [ __ ] googling where is the
nearest internet while uh internet
hotspot so i look for coffee shops right
so i'm like brilliant there's a lot more
like a mcdonald's or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah brilliant
it's just like everything you do there's
another thing yeah yeah
it's
like a side quest to complete the side
questions yeah
i have to order a drink
starbucks
brilliant there's a thali's coffee shop
like right you know i blocked down from
here so i [ __ ] sprint to this coffee
shop i don't want to buy a coffee
because that's just adding more time
once yeah i'm like outside the coffee
shop and i'm and i'm just like [ __ ]
i'm just like [ __ ] watch dogs you
know like
i take out my laptop
in the middle of the in the middle of
the street i take out my laptop open it
[ __ ] connect to the wi-fi
yeah it's like a scene of watch dogs or
something i'm just like i'm going off
the traffic lights i'm packing you up
into the mainframe i'm hacking the
system so i like downloads download my
download my statement put it in my put
it in my usb stick run back to the
[ __ ] combini then i can finally print
off the statement yeah and i'm just like
and by then 20 minutes have passed so i
[ __ ] run back to run back to the bank
and i'm just like do i have enough time
to complete this transfer and she's like
yes yes we'll make enough time don't
worry i'm like thank [ __ ] god
okay
so i hand her the statement right and
she's like okay great we can use this
yeah and then so we start we start to
start we start filling out the rest of
the form so she asked me for my british
uh account number and account details
yeah and so i whip out my uh barclays
debit card and she looks at it and she
goes
oh we could have just used that
and i'm just like
oh my god i am literally about to see it
right now
you know and if you ever ask a bank like
person like being like why didn't you
tell me that before then they'll just be
like well you did not
yeah i mean listen to the pandora's
[ __ ] box
thank you for giving me all the options
uh was there a transfer limit that you
could do
uh there wasn't a transfer limit
thankfully enough but the transfer
itself cost uh 80 dollars which is just
like
well i think i think the reason why
japanese banks because i read that up on
this uh before because i had i had to
help aki do the exact same thing right
like send money back home uh for her
parents and like yeah i had to go
through this obviously i didn't have the
problem with the google translate thing
so i got it done in one go yeah but my i
was just like jesus christ like why why
is this just such an arbitrary process
like it shouldn't take this long and
then i saw like a thing being like oh
it's because japan uh has like run into
like a lot of like money laundering
issues and i'm like
i don't know if anyone can be bold into
money launder if it takes that [ __ ]
long
to do it like not even worse honestly
it's probably a deterrent at this point
yeah like why would you money launder in
japan when
when it takes like a full day to process
i'm like i can't be [ __ ] the money
launderer anymore i'll just be a
law-abiding citizen
honestly it's probably easier to like
abide by the law than money laundered at
that point i feel like the money
laundering is is not an issue that is on
the everyday
consumers in the bank i feel like we
should really be looking at these
messages i guarantee billion dollar
transfer yeah i guarantee it was
probably like it happened maybe like
once or twice and then obviously every
japanese company when something bad
happens once or twice they get super
paranoid about and they're like guys we
have to stop this money laundering
crisis it is unstoppable make the
process as [ __ ] as possible so that
no one can be bothered to do it is that
really the reason why because i i've
noticed that like anything payment wise
japan is very easy to send money to but
very difficult to get it out of and i
just wondered if that i i just assumed
that was like japanese government being
like yeah we want money to stay here
yeah i mean that's probably also a thing
as well i'm sure the money learning is
just like a fast like like a public
thing that they just say but i think
guaranteed they're just like that's why
we don't like it yeah yeah
we don't want you breaking any laws
have you ever like sent have you ever
been scammed
via like any money
money scheme or something like that
because like i remember i remember like
the phone scams and stuff like that no
just like just like being scammed with
like transferring money and then you
never got it back with something like
that because i remember when i was uh
the only time
i've sent money that was just like i
just got completely scammed and i
rightly so got scammed because this was
when i was trying to buy a fake id when
i was when i was uh when i was underage
right well yeah i mean
i totally deserved it
no no it is i i absolutely deserved it
but i cause like i remember you know
back back when you were uk teen you know
the person who had the fake id was the
cool guy right he was the king yeah he
was the [ __ ] king he could he could
buy the drinks he you know he he could
he could buy the alcohol he whips out
the realistic looking fake id and it's
not just like the obviously like really
like obviously fake student id that yeah
from like five dollars on the
from from like some guy yeah yeah um so
so i was just like how did so i knew a
guy who had a fake id so i was like how
did you get it and he tells me this you
know really dodgy [ __ ] website and
i'm just like of course and i'm just
like am i desperate enough to uh carry
the risk of trying to purchase this id
he says that he was downloading tor
because because this is how i said
amazon
because this is how i realized because
the
you couldn't pay by a card with this
website right yeah no no no this is this
is far this is way before bitcoin uh you
have to transfer via western union
oh my god
like literally anything with that is a
stack
anything that uses i'm pretty sure
that's how western union makes money
yeah yeah which is which is which is why
i asked right because i of i obviously
because i had never heard of [ __ ]
western union yeah i was just like what
the [ __ ] is western you know about it
yeah
now i do know about it from scouts yeah
um
and so because i tried i was like i
tried sending this like i was like how
do i send money via western union is
that a bank is that like some nigerian
bank or something like like i've i've
never heard of this before and like i i
threw buying this fake idea because at
that point i was a dumb kid and i was
stupid enough to just trust you you were
desperate i was stupid and desperate you
have to just try anything to like get a
fake id it was desperate
mans was dead yeah so i was like sure
i'll i'll try this western union stuff
maybe maybe it will maybe it would work
and then i find out that you can only
send like western union uh transfers at
not even banks but like certain corner
shops in the uk right it's not it's not
even anything official it's like the
most it's like the most dodgiest places
you can send money and these are the
only places you can send money and i'm
just like maybe it'll work out maybe a
workout
that's like the equivalent of being like
you can buy this with cash but we have
to meet in an alleyway somewhere
i think i would have preferred to meet
someone in the alleyway because at least
there would be like another person i
could communicate right how much was it
how much was it it's like 30 pounds
i mean that was a lot for me as a 16
year old kid yeah whatever right
uh like uh what was that more of the
story is don't buy fake id kids it's not
worth it yeah yeah and also it's not
worth it because you didn't [ __ ] get
it yeah don't be stupid like the moment
you see western union as well turn
around like don't even bother
i know japan actually has like a lot of
scams because like you know how the
population here is very old right like
the majority of them so there's a lot of
like phone scams that happen yeah i've
heard about that and the most famous
like variety of phone scams is uh
they're called oreo
which means the me me scam
so basically how it works is a guy calls
up like an old you know granddad or a
grandfather who like they do back
research to see like do they have
grandchildren do they have a son or a
daughter and they call them up and they
go oh it's me it's me
like posing as their son or daughter
being like oh it's me it's me um i need
help you know can you get me like x
amount of money so forth and so many old
people fall for it
because
you know yeah polite in this country
yeah right yeah it's it's insane how
much like my grandma almost fell for it
one time i remember like when i was
quite young um luckily she didn't but
yeah there was they asked for like
absurd amounts of money like you know
upwards of like hundreds of thousands of
dollars just jesus just be like yeah can
you transfer it like tomorrow i'm like
desperately needed i just lost my job
blah blah blah all that kind of stuff
every year dude like all people i need
100 000 and he lost my job yeah i lost
my job i need 100 domino's pizza in
japan i need a hundred thousand dollars
i need to buy out all the domino stocks
i need one large domino's pizza from
japan hundred thousand hundred thousand
dollars
there's also the uh i think uh actually
i remember i watched videos about people
who became homeless in japan
and apparently one of the scams that
makes people homeless a lot of the time
is guarantor scams so like people uh
ask uh
people to be like guarantors on their
rent and then there's run off oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then they they have
to pay the guarantor thing and they lose
a [ __ ] ton of money yeah because most
people can't afford to pay double rent
yeah yeah which is uh the shitty thing
isn't it yeah not not to mention the key
money and like
itself
that's just a scam everyone's agreed to
i think yeah i think so at what point
does it stop being a scam and does it
just tradition is the biggest scam of
all i just i just don't understand the
point of that just being like oh yes
here is an extra month worth of rent as
a thank you for letting this peasant
stay in your abode and it's like
i'm [ __ ] paying rent every month are
you not happy with the rent i'm already
paying you money to stay in your place
and you want to pay me extra money to be
thankful that i'm paying you money
why am i thankful enough for the rent
why should i be thankful to pay you
money so yeah you have to pay one to two
months rent up front yeah depending
depending some places you don't have to
oh yeah my name is it's not a deposit
because you don't have the deposits like
everyone always asks is it a deposit no
no there's a deposit yeah which like
comes back to you after you move out but
then there's key money which just does
not return yeah yeah it's literally just
like it's just a bribe that's all it is
is
you know at least uh they don't in japan
they have to deal with like microsoft
scams and uh like the indian call
centers oh yeah sure oh my god can you
imagine that
well i think it's the reason we get them
so much because any people can speak
english
but i remember the moment indians can
start speaking japanese it's over yeah
yeah yeah it's right
it's like the moment where actual
companies move their call centers from
india to like literally any other
country yeah it's over but it's always
in india that's what makes it so hard
sometimes yeah everywhere you'd call in
the uk it was always an indian call
center especially it was internet yeah
yeah the amount of times i'd call up and
i'm like i don't know if i'm talking to
a scam because this service is so [ __ ]
you could form it no it's always like
internet and banking as well yeah right
that's always great which is two big
things yeah that's always great to have
a dad who worked in it because i'd never
needed to call them just be like father
help me please help help me i know
you're not yeah when i first uh uh
worked with buckwalker
um i was doing a promotion with them and
it was actually on one of my videos
where i prank called scammers oh yeah
and this is where i learned that they
don't have them in japan
because i'd made this video right where
i basically just called up scammers and
i just kept promoting book order to them
yeah i remember yeah you kept doing it i
kept doing it and then i would like do a
super cut of like the funniest moments
and they would get really pissed off
yeah and they would be like microsoft
and i would just be like i would just
start playing the fly surprises write
music to them and just start basically
doing a pitch
and just pissing them off yeah and then
whenever they block my number i'd make a
new number and i call them again yeah
yeah yeah and so i filmed it and it was
great it was really funny bit it was
like two minutes long and it was great
of me and it was great promotion because
yeah yeah i mean that series was doing
really well he was literally just doing
ad reads for two minutes to
indian and call centers yeah yeah um and
uh yeah and then i sent it off to book
walker and i was like oh god they might
not like it oh and then they were like
yeah okay it looks uh looks good uh will
we get in trouble with microsoft for
doing this
[Laughter]
and i was like the truth comes out
microsoft backing up scanners
because when we called them up yeah they
were obviously pretending to be
microsoft yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh is microsoft okay with you doing this
how did you harass their employees
do we need approval from microsoft thing
what
being broken they're like no way that's
a thing that's a thing and i was like
i think it was
actually
you know when you call up microsoft you
know who's gonna answer but cortana's
gonna answer you first oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah but
really
it was fake but i was i had to make sure
oh yeah so it's even worse because
marilyn's american americans should have
known this yeah
if you are actually scaring me right now
i'm not sure
[Applause]
oh my god do i have your words
do i have your word i can trust you
right
can i get a hanko proving you're not a
my god
yeah that is true actually now that i
think about it we don't have anything
like that in japan to be honest right
because think about it even if mailing
says that she jokes saying proof right
what what's stopping a japanese company
from saying uh we're providing tech
support yeah they get their hanko stamp
their japanese governments they start
calling up people saying hi we're
microsoft they probably wouldn't get
shut down for a while probably not
because even if the report gets filed
the japanese government will take five
[ __ ] years to analyze
and decide and by then they'll be
[ __ ] dipped out yeah and then they'll
have 10 new networks and companies
i hope none of the indian scammers see
this
like gentlemen we are expanding
dave knows no hunger
get him in
he knows
keiko
who's seen anime here who's watched
anime
i've been getting into like the uh you
know the youtube channels that uh really
look into the indium scammers like i
think jim browning yeah i'm a big fan of
them all yeah i i really love what jim
browning does and i don't know what like
uh i don't know some of the other people
as well some of the people who actually
just phone them back up as well and just
really troll them i remember i saw one
guy who got an indian scammer so [ __ ]
angry that he was literally shouting
yeah on the phone
have you watched like uh if it was like
yeah kit burger do you watch it
he does the ones where he does like
uh like uh what's the inverse speed runs
i guess slow running oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah he tries to keep them on the phone
for as long as possible yeah yeah and i
swear he's he on average gets it like
four or five hours holy [ __ ] and just
wastes that time he's far too good at
sounding like an old grandma yeah he's
not an american grandma he's he's he's
too good he's a filter but he also like
does a really good job yeah and he's got
the mannerisms down perfectly because he
just does it all day yeah yeah
so he's he's there pretending to be an
old grandma for like six hours
it's in sex
he works with the voice coach apparently
oh really oh my god
that's someone dedicated to that
people get like nine hours though
[ __ ]
and then yeah and then at the end the
reveal is so great because you could
just hear like how [ __ ] annoyed the
person
also these scammers get so [ __ ] angry
not fast enough yeah you hear some of
them where they're like like no go to
warm up now get the google play card now
now you're done [ __ ] they're like
shouting at them
yeah this is some good questions
this is still better than like virgin
media uk as well
i remember because like oh what uh what
clocked me on that was like it was
recommended that i got recommended just
a random clip of just an indie guy like
shouting at full [ __ ] volume
why are you so dumb why are you so
stupid why are you doing that and i'm
just like what the [ __ ] yeah if you like
clicked the wrong thing yeah yeah it's
like traumatizing for these older people
yeah i bet
jesus christ like someone could murder
my mother and i don't think i'd be as
angry as that like jesus christ
like what the hell man
there's some really good jim browning
ones where he like gets to like passport
information on their pc and he like
shows it to them that's really [ __ ]
good
yeah yeah yeah it's good check out jim
browning if you're uh like if you ever
want to fall down a rabbit hole and uh
just wonder what is actually on the
other side of whoever like phones up
phones you up and tries to scam people
all right good i mean if every one of
those people that's uh calling them back
and [ __ ] with them it's uh saves you
know one person's uh money and time yeah
i mean that if anyone deserves to be
[ __ ] with it's it's scams scammers
right yeah because you know even if you
you're quite savvy with this stuff it is
you know you're unlikely to if you hear
an indian accent calling you and telling
you hey you need to pay extra money to
microsoft you're probably not gonna fall
for it but yeah you know that's because
we know yeah but also the old people
older generation have no idea right yeah
yeah i have a distinct memory from when
i was like
10
of my mum coming to me being like you
know our friend apparently microsoft
called them up and said that they have
some of the worst viruses in the world
on their pc
and i was like wow really really and
that was all i heard of it a week later
she comes back she's like turns out it
was a scam and they lost
and they lost 1 000 pounds
just for inflation that's like 10 grand
they said that they had the y2k bug
this was around that time i think yeah
i know it wasn't actually it's actually
yeah
i was very very young and i just have
this weird memory being like that sounds
strange that sounds dumb
why would microsoft call you up why
would they not just nuke your pc yeah
right
the thing that i've had to teach my
parents is like if there were those
there was a period when they just were
not tech savvy at all i mean like they
still don't exactly take savvy but at
least they were not tech savvy enough to
even attempt to go on the internet and
go on facebook and do that and stuff and
it was the point where they started to
take more of an interest of being online
and stuff like that that it really was
kind of like stepping on eggshells when
trying to explain to them that some
emails are not real and some emails are
scams and it's just like some sometimes
sometimes my mom just like will send me
a message to be like is this is should i
click on this link should i click on
that and like i don't know how to
properly convey
which sometimes like which emails are
legit and which emails are not legit
it's kind of like explaining to someone
over the phone how to defuse a bomb
sometimes i told my parents right i said
even if you get the email saying your
account's been hacked or anything like
that yeah i said i told them and the
same with numbers as well uh because my
dad
nearly i think nearly fell for one a few
times
and i always told him just just call
them back like call the go like if you
get called by your bank go to the bank's
website call them yeah you know just
immediately don't talk yeah yeah because
you know odds are your bank isn't going
to call you and if they do they'll
probably ask you a bunch of weird stuff
yeah if all like you know any like
social media gets compromised quote
unquote from an email
yeah i nearly [ __ ] fell for that uh
the google adsense thing yeah
fell for it yeah yeah yeah i actually
didn't get that really yeah dude you're
lucky man if jim browning fell for it
anyone can yeah i saw his video on it
actually
it is it's waringly convincing but
that's the thing right it's like it's
hard to like convey to you you know your
parents or your grandparents like yeah
you know how to identify between a scam
email not a scammer because i feel every
year it's just get like that line is
getting narrower
it's getting too good which is why like
which is why i find it so hard to
explain to them because sometimes i
se i have to like second guess myself
and i'm just like if i'm second-guessing
myself
and i literally grew up on the inside i
work on the internet yeah
how can my parents who have little to no
knowledge of internet culture
tell the difference how am i supposed to
convey that through text or through
phone to be like just just don't believe
any email you get sent basically what up
lads it's your boy here to let you know
that this episode of trash tastes is
sponsored by girl cafe gun gold cafe gun
is an arpg game that integrates tps
combat and has beautiful visuals and
graphics powered by life2d build your
dream waifu team by collecting multiple
character cards use multiple fighting
abilities and strategies by switching
characters during intense gunfights do
you want to prove to the world that you
have a more galaxy brain than that of
britannia then this is definitely the
game for you my lads during the battle
the characters are oversimplified into q
version which can satisfy different
preferences of players plus it's not all
guns and fighting if you want to run
your own virtual cafe the game's got you
covered with a plethora of customizable
decorations for you to choose from and
different types of coffee to boot
discover your own business sense by
satisfying the needs of your lovely
customers not only that but you can also
enjoy the diverse bonding system with
high fidelity social interactions
including tickling gift giving moments
sharing and private messaging yes you
heard me right my boys and girls
you can tickle your waifu in this game i
mean not only do we have some of the
most beautiful and aesthetic anime
waifus that we have seen in a long time
but you can god damn tickle your waifus
in this game i had to say that again
because that's important information so
if you'd like to tickle your waifus and
enjoy a great game then make sure to
check out girl cafe gun by clicking the
link down in the description below and
thank you for sponsoring this episode
back to the show i remember the first
time that maylene messaged me like to
work with bulk walker yeah i thought it
was a scare honestly honestly i thought
the same thing as well
i was just like i was just like i was
like no way this is real hold on a
second it says cuddle color i'm like the
cuddle color nah and i i swear the first
one i [ __ ] deleted it immediately i
was like nah that's a scam get out of
that and then meleen misses me like
emailed me again after a week and she's
like i don't know if you read my last
email but uh we're interested in working
with you and i'm like
oh this [ __ ] don't delete that again oh
there was a it was a youtuber who uh
they got uh
like offered a role to voice an anime
yeah by by funimation right and it was a
scam and they publicly announced that
they'd gotten the role right in the show
and it was just a fake email
i don't think i've cringed out of body
in pain for someone else more of my life
i i laughed but that was that is just
that is just that that's a that's a bra
moment if if i did that [ __ ] and i found
out it was a scam i would just quit
socially i think i would i think i would
yeah i would just disappear from the
show yeah also you know generally when
you get roles and stuff
yeah so i guess maybe it was like a test
he was like yeah no rolls for you gotcha
it's like willy wonka it's like ah you
were too greedy no road for you
maybe it was really funimation they just
needed to pass the test
it's like indiana jones like the holy
grail yeah ah you chose greed no
no because like going back going back to
the book walking emails that we first
got i think i i think looking back
maelynn must have emailed me way earlier
before i actually replied for the first
time and what caught me to reply was
meeting you for the first time and being
like oh yeah that that email from
megalin that did you get an email for
mailing as well and i was just like
that's not a scam that's real
that was real this entire time
i remember i've just been ghosting her
and deleting all the emails i remember i
think that i think i sent that email to
about like
three or four different family members
just to be like does this look fake
because i'm really scared to reply to
this [ __ ] and get like a virus cause
like i don't even know luckily it wasn't
but uh yeah yeah i don't know if it was
the way that like mainly wrote the email
or what it was yes i'm playing blaming
maylene
i don't know i think i think it was just
before this was before the point of
annietube where
we thought any kind of companies yeah
like yeah
because before that like the biggest cup
like i had not worked with any big
company right it was always like you
know like that's true actually like yeah
it was it was not i was still tiny back
then as well so i was like no no i i
can't this jump is too high that's
what's way too unrealistic
i mean yeah i mean arguably book walker
kind of like paved the way in that way i
feel like book walker opened up i took
the bullet
for everyone yeah
yeah
i was like i'll take it for the for the
good of the people
did you see this the youtube scam though
did you see what like
i saw what it was about because i think
literally ever all of my other friends
got that email including you guys and uh
yeah and so i was scared i was i was
sifting through my email as well and i
didn't get one it's so essentially what
happened was is that i got an email from
a google email yeah that said oh uh
the message was sent like oh you have a
duplicate adsense account um
and you know your channel will be
deleted and i think that is one of the
rules of adsense is that if you do
actually have multiple adsense accounts
you will yeah yeah you'll get banned
yeah that you can only have one adsense
account and they do send an email like
that as well yeah yeah i only have one
adsense account but uh we had multiple
channels so maybe i thought oh my god
there must be a mix up because you know
i recently just had the new channel and
yeah so yeah it was kind of but this is
often how scams work though as well they
prey on
very coincidental circumstances that
have been happening outside of the scam
itself yeah yeah you know like jim
browning said in his thing it's like
yeah sometimes you order you just order
the product of amazon 10 minutes later
you get a scam email about amazon yeah
people cure pure coincidence but it
happens to play off a little bit right
yeah concerns so yeah it's this thing
and the one thing that was probably the
red flag which i think did make me
unsure but again i was kind of so
worried that i was like oh i should just
i i went to hear him out at least it was
through google hangouts yeah but it was
a google email so i was like okay well
it's a bit weird because normally they
would just but then again i've never had
correspondence through google because
there's no [ __ ] at talking to you yeah i
don't even know how they would reach out
to me yeah because they've done email in
the past but sometimes they haven't so i
don't really understand i think that
also is one of the reasons why people
did fall for them because youtube is so
unclear and how they reach out i mean i
mean the the only the only time i've
ever talked to google correctly is when
i've through twitter yeah yeah i've
spoken to them i've never had someone
reach out to me yeah yeah it never
happened so i so i'm talking to them and
they're going through the thing and
they're like oh um yeah you have a
duplicate adsense account and i'm like
that doesn't sound right i don't have
the duplicate adsense account they're
like oh well you do and i'm like okay
well what's what's the id on the adsense
account adsense accounts of ids yeah and
he gave me an id and it was just like
not even remotely close to
anything and i was like oh um okay well
that's that's weird and i was like um
can you tell me about the account then
what's what's the duplication and you
couldn't tell me anything yeah it's all
private it's all private which would
would kind of make sense you know yeah
and i was like okay we're fine fine all
right well i was like can you tell me
that you're a google employee can you
show some proof and he was like no
and i was like
because i'm not
i was like all right scooby doo mask
reveal at this point and then what he
was trying to do and he was um you can
make multiple youtube accounts under one
email yeah and so he told me to make a
new youtube account
um so i did this because i was just
curious to see what the steps he was
telling me to do were yeah because i
knew none of this was permanent and
doesn't really matter if you make a new
account yeah it doesn't like delete
anything so he told me to make a new
youtube account and then go to the
youtube uh account management page and
then set to have the new account that i
made take over the old channel now what
this does is that it deletes all the
videos right and deletes everything
especially like a factory reset it kind
of just
puts like it's just like this channel
it's like and you know
plaster it on top yeah yeah yeah brand
new
nothing else was here before right
that's kind of it it's a cover-up right
yeah and then you know so and it just
deletes everything yeah and then he was
telling me to do that and and so i got
to the point where i i clicked on like
the i wanted to see what the menu was to
do it and i was going through steps and
it was like
delete everything except for like likes
and comments and stuff and i'm like what
the [ __ ] that's weird
but uh and and then i was like no this
doesn't seem right this this seems a
little weird yeah and so uh i was like
yeah sorry i'm gonna contact youtube
myself because i don't i don't trust
this at all and so i close the chat i
contact youtube like hey is anything
wrong with my account you know is uh
everything's gonna be deleted he's like
no that's all good i'm like you're sure
this guy said it was and he's like no no
it's all good i was like oh
okay then i guess i'll carry on and then
i found out it was a big steal and yeah
multiple fallen for it yeah yeah i mean
i think the problem was that you just
even if you wanted to ask an official
person that youtube
who would you contact yeah i had to i
had to like do a web chat with someone
at google mm-hmm
how'd you do that oh is that possible
yeah yeah you can do like a web chat
there are real employees at google i
don't know if it's real
i
probably just might like the most
advanced air
information and stuff and yeah it was
actually surprisingly easy but you know
that's i think that was
that might have been just youtube i
don't know you know i it's all about
that's the thing that's the problem so
everything is so hidden in secrecy that
if someone did come up to you and was
like this is who we are we're google
we're youtube you have a problem then
like most people like especially for the
smaller youtubers they wouldn't know any
better because they're probably thinking
themselves well i guess you know i no
one's really told me how to contact
google i guess this is how they contact
you right and that's probably why so
many people fell for it
yeah oh i i oh sorry did you have
something to say no no that was it yeah
jim brownie fell for it and a few other
big names yeah the spiffing brit i think
fell for it as well lots of big
youtubers fall for yeah i mean it's
connecting i mean i i just remembered i
almost fell for like a scam recently
actually
um because my friend's facebook account
got hacked and
and uh
yeah and so his his account got hacked
and so the person who hacked his account
was like really clever and sent like a
mass message out yeah i got it as well
yeah like a mass message out to like i
think everywhere just everyone on this
contacts list right just saying hey like
uh i'm i really need a favor right now
do you have a java in it right and if if
it was obviously a bot running it
because if you replied anything else but
i like a pre-determined script right
then it would just like block you or it
would like just close the message or
something like that so so a bunch of
people including sydney right because
this is when i i actually got the
message while we were recording trash
taste right um yeah yeah yeah so that's
why i didn't see the message but sydney
saw the message and she was like yeah
what's going on and the message was like
because it felt like a natural
conversation because the bot had already
pre-determined it's like a certain
conversation route that people could
take um it ended up being like uh it
ended up being a conversation chain that
says that where he said that he was
locked out of his um i think i think
like he was locked out or something or
he he needed to pay the rent today and
no he was locked out of his bank account
right and he needed to pay rent to
western union
only accepting western union no not
western union but um he needed to pay
his rent or he was going to get kicked
out or something yeah and uh he needed
to transfer money to the uh
to the uh to his landlord so he was like
can you please transfer money to a
certain bank account and i'll cover it
when i get my bank account back and i'll
pay you interest as well right and like
so sydney was phoning me afterwards
being like yo yo yo go on go on have you
have you seen the message dude dude he's
like mike's in a lot of trouble you
gotta you gotta send money and me i was
just like okay because he came from
sydney and sydney sounded so desperate
so i didn't even read the message so i
was like okay i guess i guess i gotta
send the [ __ ] money right so uh so
before i send the money thankfully i
checked i checked the message that my
mate sent me and by that point
thankfully
like i i remember seeing the message and
then just suddenly it just disappeared
and his accounts got just got deleted
yeah it was like uh because when i when
i saw it like the facebook was back to
the default yeah yeah yeah that's weird
so like i was i was this close to just
sending him money because he's a good
man you know you always got to get your
mates back yeah of course and it was it
was really [ __ ] convincing cause i
saw the messages some other people got
because unfortunately uh we have a
pretty good pretty big friend group and
unfortunately two people ended up
sending him sending him money oh no and
i saw like the conversation chain it was
genuinely interes it was genuinely
convincing because it wasn't just a one
message thing it was a genuine
conversation just a really well made
bought right yeah yeah yeah it was a
really well made board and i'm just like
jesus christ i mean i probably would
have fallen for it as well because he's
he's he's a good man that's the thing
right that's scary especially when it's
coming from like a friend right yeah
yeah i don't know i feel in that
situation like i think the best thing to
do maybe is to like call them up
you know just like double check right
yeah like
yeah i i think that's what it's very
hard to it's it's it's a little easier
to fake a chat room than it is to fake a
phone i think i think if uh if you know
you did phone in before then
then it would have been sorted out yeah
sometimes you know it was worded in the
way where he just he just needed it now
and and yeah and that's the scary thing
right now that's just getting better and
better that that's probably where having
a japanese bank account would be an
advantage because you'd be like
sorry sorry i've got to like book an
appointment
for tomorrow
can you wait a week
that's the next open slot on my back you
know the next quarter is in like three
months that's obviously the best
i can do i can't get a statement until
like three months from now i'm sorry
dude you're gonna have to try something
else yeah i'm i'm sorry man
can't do internet banking transitions
anyway enough about scams i'm going to
hijack this podcast for a moment turn it
back into an anime podcast what
because i i just i i i need to i just i
just need to okay
i just i just i just i i just just let
me have this let me have this corner let
me have this because i uh i know exactly
what you're gonna talk about
of course you do i don't of course you
do joey so this weekend i watched the
new uh evangelical movie
and i just i i did not see this coming
he was literally tweeting about it all
week i i need to talk about this because
i can't i i need to move on with my this
man this man's tweeted about it like he
watched like 13 reasons why for the
first time i'm glad i'm glad though we
finally watched it because again i i
watched it on the day it came out in the
cinemas which was like [ __ ] six
months ago or something it was a really
really long time ago and i was like i
want to talk about it so bad on the
podcast but these two haven't seen it so
i'm just gonna like i'm just gonna
bottle this emotion up and now i can
finally pop the bottle yeah like like i
talked about it i watched it and i
literally like cannot move moderate in
my life like
like like it's like witnessing the death
of a family member you know it's like
it's like actually mortifying i'm like
oh my god so yeah it's no more good or
bad kind of death like a weird cousin
that you didn't really like okay
i don't know how to like
possibly convey the feeling i felt but
what i will say is that i mean like i
shouldn't have just i shouldn't have
ever been a monk at all right that was
that was like that was a [ __ ] that
was a [ __ ] scam because if i wanted
to feel zen if i wanted to reach nirvana
i should have i should have just been an
ava fan right because i fell more then
after the end of eva after this end of
favor than i ever did as a monk was it
that good it was uh it's it's like it's
the type of movie that you can't just
clean
it's the type of movie that you can't
just clean up with the word good yeah or
bad yeah because it's neither of those
it's just like that sounds like it's
mediocre it's no it's not normally
definitely not media it's anything it's
not mediocre yeah
it is the polar opposite of mediocre
yeah i saw the imdb page the reviews
were kind of you know
all over the place yeah yeah
it was around about seven eight it's
like i think the only way i can describe
that last movie is do you have to have a
very iq to understand
you have to honestly
actually like
i'm not even getting like that's why
they called it three point
three point one point which is like the
most pretentious fight yeah it's very
difficult to figure out that that's full
and you can't perform rudimentary
mathematics then you just not all even
allowed you watched the original avo
when it got released on netflix right
yeah i did what was your opinions of the
tv series the time yeah
[Music]
it was fine i you know i
i i i
understand why everyone
is so hyped about it yeah yeah um
i could see why you'd watch this and you
would remember this yeah yeah but i
didn't think it was that amazing right
yeah i think i think that's like i i
think that's the comment
it leaves an impression yeah i think
i'll say that much yeah you know and you
can't you know it's this isn't like
the irregular high school whatever the
[ __ ] that one is where you're like
you're like i literally don't even know
who you are and i'm 20 episodes into
this like i don't know there's four
seasons of that [ __ ] as well yeah yeah
yeah i mean i don't even know that yeah
i i i there's like a spin-off coming
this season as well and it's like it's
well yeah you know it's one of those
shows that definitely was like i
understand entirely why this is iconic
and everyone is in love with this yeah i
just personally wasn't that into it did
you did you leave satisfied no not at
all okay good good yes because i was
like because that that was my experience
that was the worst part yeah
let me ask you then did you leave
satisfied uh with the original waiver no
no no with 4.0 oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
tv series
it was [ __ ] i don't know the tv series
left everyone unsatisfied i mean i mean
like i remember the first two times i
watched ava i [ __ ] hated it yeah yeah
michael because the first time i watched
it i was 12. of course i was
of course i was not going to understand
ava when i was 12 and then i re-watched
it not enough iq yeah i re-watched it to
review it as an annie tuber and then i
was just like this is even worse than i
remember it right because now i now i'm
actually invested in the characters in
the world and the mysteries that you
actually understand it's sort of yeah it
felt like a slap in the face yeah yeah
yeah
someone who of course yeah all day
watching it i just what did i end up
with applause and congratulations let's
see
is this it yeah this is it it's like the
show was mocking me like congratulations
you sat through all of this for nothing
yeah so they could what milk foot like
another 50 years out of this of movies
was five hit in there yeah yeah yeah he
was landing ahead he was [ __ ] five
minutes and then i remember i remember
going on the internet [ __ ] angry and
i'm just like surely that can't be the
ending and then people were just like yo
have you heard of this movie called and
in the favor end of angelion which is
the end of it which which is uh
i mean it is and end
whether you are satisfied with that ends
up like the alternative ending one
yeah it's alternative but it's also
canon
yeah so so
so kind of kind of the history behind
the first two
the the tv series ending is that as you
can probably tell the uh studio just
kind of ran out of money and ran out of
like budget so they had to like piece
together something right
um and so that was the ending that you
saw and so either like either fans were
so unsatisfied that they sent ano and
the
company death threats or anna himself
was unsatisfied with the ending that he
decided to make a bunch of clapping
let's just start yeah let's make let's
make another ending to ava and that's
the end of van gaalion and people were
just like all right i'm ready now this
is this is this is the ending that's we
never got it's finally the title of the
movie it's called end of ever and it's
not even the ending right that's what i
understand it's a ending it's it's it's
definitely a ending but it definitely
doesn't
leave you satisfied what's the one
shoulder of
even going what order one no no
tv show then movies uh okay so 1.0 uh is
basically the first i'd say 15 episodes
right there's an abridged movie yeah
it's basically just like a cliff notes
version of the tv series and then 2.0
the first half of 2.0 it approaches the
original ending of the tv series but
then goes on a different oh that's
[ __ ] cheeky that yeah yeah so
this is this air in theaters yeah
these cheeky [ __ ]
made one third of a movie and called it
a day pretty much yeah oh my god maybe i
should just make [ __ ] things and
re-release them again in future and add
another 20 so basically the second half
of 2.0 uh and you know mind you i don't
fully remember everything because it was
a while since i watched it but i do i'm
pretty sure
all right so i'm talking to someone who
literally knows every frame of the first
movie because i [ __ ] abridged it
so so like 1.0 is basically just almost
a shot for short recreation of like the
first
four or five episodes and then oh with
cleaner art right yeah with cleaner arts
and minor minor minor differences then
2.0 like it's still like very very
similar to like episodes maybe like six
to 18 ish for [ __ ] so yeah i mean it's
it's it it goes it has other differences
it introduces a new character which is
the go of glasses and it has other like
minor differences but for the most part
it's pretty much the same and then like
introducing a whole new character is not
the same i mean you're the same until
you introduce the yeah yeah it's the
same until you introduce her and then
3.0 and 4.0 which i'm going to go which
i'm going to call 4.0 because three plus
one is four what is that
yeah it is it's an [ __ ] called no
hideyaki yeah
are like completely different so it's
like almost like a that's completely
original yeah it's it's like the first
time you walk you walked into starbucks
and realized it was not medium small
large yeah why why did you do this like
which one's venti which one's that i
don't know what's that
medium i still don't know what a [ __ ]
venti is i i still don't understand no
the part that [ __ ] me up was like tall
is not large yeah yeah yeah yeah tall is
medium tallest
this is why i just like the chart i can
see the price that's how i do yeah yeah
yeah yeah anyway sorry go on back to the
four point nine
four yeah so anyway so 3.0 and 4.0 are
completely original yeah um so i watched
i said okay so i watched 3.0 on the day
it came out in cinemas i was 16 when
that came out okay
so it was literally 10 years ago and i
only seen it once yeah so imagine me
going to the cinemas day one airing on
4.0 right and i'm like
and i was like i got this
literally the first five minutes of 4.0
it does a recap and i'm like oh thank
god that's great because there's a
10-year gap right yeah so it goes
through like super fast like super
artistic way of just being like here's
what happened to 1.0 here's what
happened two-pointer he's what happened
3.0 goes through 1.0 i'm like okay yeah
this is just the tv series i've seen tv
series many times got it in the bag 2.0
i was like okay yep stole the tv series
but introduced the new character all
right cool yeah 3.0 i'm just like
i don't remember any of that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on and then 4.0
just begins and i was like
cool
so i'm literally going into this movie
with maybe about
a five percent understanding of what has
happened so far it's it's it's all good
man because i don't think that would
have helped you at all um because i the
reason i didn't i chose not to see it in
cinemas right was because obviously it
wasn't subtle in japanese
with a series like ava i wanted to at
least try to understand what was going
on yeah because i did i did remember
what happened in 3.0 so i was like i
remember most of the plot points so i'll
be able to follow along easily um so
finally i waited for it to come out and
i was just like i should have just seen
this in theaters because i have as much
of an understanding of what's going on
in my own language than i do in a
[ __ ] other language that i'm like
barely understanding
for me 4.0 was like all right cool
that's a line i understood what they
were saying i think i'm starting to get
it and then literally the next line i'm
like i don't understand what's going on
and i'm like this is a language i am
fluent this is my first language that
they're speaking in it sounds like a
different language there's just so much
terminology being thrown around which
yeah i'm sure there was some kind of
explanation of probably in 3.0 yeah but
of course i have a 10-year gap with 3.0
obviously i don't remember that [ __ ] the
definitive way to watch it is to watch
three and immediately immediately start
fall
probably i don't think it even matters
because i i don't remember it i i doubt
a lot of people are going to be able to
follow along in their first watch
through anywhere because so much
terminology gets [ __ ] thrown around
and just gets like pulled out of his ass
like like some some of the scenes i'm
just like i know i don't know if you're
a genius or a madman like
oh yeah and then here's the more [ __ ]
up thing that i realized if there's
anything i got out of 4.0 it's the fact
that there is literally information in
4.0 you will have no idea what the [ __ ]
it is unless you read the manga yeah
yeah i think arno literally took every
iteration it was like it took bits from
the tv series it took bits from end of
favor it took even little bits from
death and rebirth yeah and the manga and
just combined it all together so it's
like if you're missing
that's the other movie
yeah
it's just basically a recap movie yeah
it's a recap movie but there's like
small minor details in death and rebirth
that are only specific to death and
reboot but like i have like for someone
like you i wouldn't even recommend
watching exhausted
end of a uh get into evangelion as a
franchise then yeah you need to watch
end of ava yeah but like i mean it
depends on it depends on what you're
looking for because if you're just
looking for like a normal tv series a
normal story to get like entertained so
much so where you know you're looking
for like a normal plot arc you're
looking for mysteries to be solved
that's just not going to happen as
you've just experienced once i think
what's so special about ava is that it's
a series that's just so powerful that
if you kind of relate to what anno was
trying to portray on screen like you
said yourself you could tell why a lot
of people thought this like a lot of
people saw this as like a really
powerful series that affected them right
and it's just because it is just that
raw and powerful because ava to me ava
like i didn't get ava the first few
times i watched it like i said i was
like i [ __ ] hated that yeah and then
like i reached later i reached a period
in life later where i started to like
[ __ ] resonate more with what was
being portrayed on screen i wouldn't say
i understood the entire plot but i don't
think that's the point of favor i don't
think the point of favor is to
understand the plot i don't think the
point of ava is to like you know you
can't just look at the shiny robots
fighting the big monsters if you want
but i think i think the true magic of
favor was just i know pouring his heart
out on screen and capturing like it's
kind of like capturing his psyche in a
sense yeah and that's why it's like
that's why you can view it and this and
you can just be like i don't get it this
is a complete [ __ ] minecraft which it is
it is enough yeah i truly think
especially with 4.0 i truly think the
only person on the planet who can fully
understand 4.0 and all of ava is anna
yeah it's because there's probably
working on the movie they're like no so
what is it i i guarantee i guarantee you
because 4.0 i feel especially 4.0 is
like a true not only is it like a true
love letter to ava but there's so much
stuff that arno just crammed into it
that really has nothing to do with ava
it's literally like he just threw it in
because he likes it yeah and i feel
that's what ava is it's it's like it's
literally a series that anna was like i
like robots i like monsters i like kaiju
fights i love all of this [ __ ] that i
personally enjoy i'm gonna cram this
[ __ ] into one series and that's ava
yeah cause like you like you like bojack
right yeah i still haven't watched the
last season i'm too scared yeah because
i i feel like bojack is probably the
closest kind of like closest big
american show that i can compare to avoc
because both deal
is the average carter
get in the robot bojack i mean it is
kinda it's it's such a weird comparison
but that that is stringy
it's
bojack was like
i guess bojack was very clear in what it
was trying to portray yeah i guess i was
slightly confused many times during eva
i'm like yeah am i supposed to feel
sorry for shinji
yeah because i both are the kind of same
with what they tried to tackle they
tried to tackle broken characters trying
to just find value in themselves and
just live with themselves right that's
that's what both series tried to do
bojack has a much more structured you
know much more structured story much
more defined character arcs and it's
just easier to follow and less technical
[ __ ] i felt like you know you in
bojack you got to like see
why he was so [ __ ] up and i felt like
in evangelion we didn't really learn
much about shinji
and he was just whining i definitely
feel like i don't i mean i think the
finer details are there if for people
who want to look into a deeper but i
feel especially the movies do a really
good job in portraying shinji as this
like broken kid yeah because i mean he's
a 14 year old kid who has like massive
daddy issues because his dad's an
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] he never grew
up with his mom um he's forced to pilot
a [ __ ] giant robot at the age of 14
and has to say he's sad about this
i mean i'm not gonna obviously not gonna
see any spoils for 4.0 but yeah
especially in 4.0 his dad is [ __ ] yeah
he's like i didn't think his dad could
get even more [ __ ] yeah oh my god you
know it's like it goes from like one to
a hundred i'm like
you cannot be seen yeah but i i think
like the the reason ava is such an
important series to so many people
including myself is that it just hits
these emotional notes that i've just
never seen in any other piece of media
and i just i think that's because i know
i didn't give a [ __ ] about pl
and i didn't give a [ __ ] about telling a
you know a story that was easy to follow
he just wanted to like put something out
there he just wanted to put his emotions
into something and that's what i feel
from him and that's why it's so like to
so many people this is such an important
thing because it's it's rare that you
see something that isn't like that isn't
so well defined but that you can relate
to on in an emotional sense it's it's
like it's almost not storytelling like
under is not really storytelling as he
is almost just emoting i i i really
can't describe ava without sounding like
that pretentiously
right yeah you know because because i
hear myself and i'm just like it's kind
of just art you know
it's one of those things where i i think
i
definitely would tv shows and media
as opposed to traditional art yeah i i
very much
prefer it when they essentially tell me
tell what they're trying yeah of course
this is like you know and as much as you
could argue oh okay well that's that's
for dumb people and whatnot it's like
also like well you know i feel that
if it is art
i suppose it can be but then also
sometimes it isn't marketed as such yeah
you know like when you look at a
painting there's no doubt in your mind
that it's art and you can interpret it
however you want and yeah you get
whatever you want out of it but i think
with tv shows because it's such a
different medium it's you know what is
art supposed to be when it's tv and film
but i would argue that some of the best
shows are the ones that can present an
artistic idea in an artistic way yeah
make it simple enough for anyone to
enjoy right yeah like i feel that's like
really just good storytelling that's why
i think bojack horseman is amazing yeah
yeah
i felt like it it delivered a topic that
i think a lot of people and a lot of
older people yeah don't really think
about or don't talk about yeah yeah yeah
and i think like i'm not bringing down
bojack because i also think it's an
amazing [ __ ] show um i i just think
like a van gallon was is so unique
because you know
if there's one thing that doesn't make
[ __ ] sense or you can't logically
always follow it's emotions right
sometimes you just feel something you're
just like why the [ __ ] why the [ __ ] do i
feel this like i logically don't know
why i feel this and i shouldn't feel
this and like
and like that's what ava portrays so
well it's not meant to be logical in a
lot of senses but sometimes you just see
something i'm just like i don't know why
i
kind of relate to this but i just do i
don't know why i resonate with this but
i just do and it's that's that's been my
experience with ava and i guess the
biggest thing that i never got from ava
was the satisfying conclusion of like
closure like this is it an actual ending
like this is this is it right i am
satisfied because you know we i kind of
you know as a naval fan you can find you
found your own [ __ ] closure you
watched end of favor and you're like
what the [ __ ] did i just watch i i need
someone sometimes you need someone to
help you process what you just watched
and like you know that sometimes you
spend hours
reading up analysis and reading up this
and reading up that and you're just like
end of favor is one of those movies
where like you watch it and you go that
was awesome but then the moment your
brain actually kicks in and goes but do
you know what it was about that's the
moment that's the moment when you have
like the existential adrenaline
wait maybe it wasn't good
why do you think i i didn't enjoy or
connect with evangelion do you reckon
there's a reason why i feel maybe it's
because you were kind of over hyped
from like the outside i i think like i
think i think
what are your expectations coming in
yeah something deep
maybe that's what it is right because
ava is like if ava is simultaneously the
deepest thing but also at the same time
something that doesn't make any [ __ ]
sense yeah i mean it's not something you
watch to per se enjoy because i remember
like the only times i've actually like
actually
kind of understood ava really depended
on depended on what mindset i was in i
couldn't just yeah i i thought i was
under the impression that it was going
to be some form of interesting take on
like being a teenager and struggling
with mental health issues it was i mean
to a certain point yeah i mean it it it
is it's just not told in a way that is
just traditional you know it's told in a
very
raw [ __ ] it's taught in a very raw way
where it's just it's they don't care
about you following the story they just
wanted to like put these raw thoughts
and raw emotions put it on screen and
then just like just put it out there
that's that's what i like that's what i
got from here which is why like the the
time that i connected with ava the most
just happened to be the point when i was
in the worst point in my life yes you
know it's it's just it's just it's just
something where
it's not something i think people should
watch to enjoy i think people should
watch it to experience it and maybe you
didn't enjoy this time i didn't enjoy it
the first time i watched it but maybe
there would be a point when you just
like where some of the words or
something from it rang out to you and
just like
maybe this is
saying that ava is an acquired taste
no joey stop putting words in my mouth
and what what i will say about end of
vavo i'm not over 4.0 without spoiling
what happens because i'm not going to
spoil that experience the only thing i
will kind of say is that it is it is a
conclusive full stop yeah and i remember
because growing up i can't like i don't
know how to convey to you what it's like
growing up with a franchise and being
like this is good this franchise is
going to be around forever there is
never going to be an end for this
franchise you kind of make peace with
that right yeah because i remember when
the movie got released i think i
remember we were memeing up to be like
oh i can't wait for 5.00 like 20 years
can't wait for i know to like dig up the
grave a favor and i remember like i
talked to plenty of japanese people who
were just like no this is this is the
end i was like sure sure yeah joey go
sees it nabi go sees it and they're like
this is the end i'm like sure
all right
it's literally uh you won't believe it
until you see it yeah yeah it is it is
and then i'll i'll watch the movies i
mean i mean you you can shoot i like i'm
not like i have like i've decided i'm
going to watch you gonna watch that you
haven't decided when i watch the movie
where yeah i think all four movies are
on uh prime video yeah netflix and all
of end of ever uh all of eve evangeline
the original series is on netflix and
all of the movies are on prime video so
they're easy to access i'm actually
planning to do like a watch party of all
four of the movies just because like why
not because like again i've only seen
3.0 and 4.0 once and i'm like well like
on the stream yeah on star wars you
press play yeah yeah yeah because like
twitch has a thing i might do that okay
yeah there's a thing for that now
like a like a watch party function what
does it look like so so basically it's
like the twitch thing it i think this is
a relatively new thing but basically
when you do a watch party together now
when you go to that person's twitch page
the person the person streaming is
actually in the corner now and you get
prompted to log into your prime video on
netflix oh [ __ ] and it likes
and it syncs up yeah dude it's like a
brand new thing now yeah my twitter
streamed
yeah so so my twitch partner was like oh
since all the ava movies are on prime
video and twitch has this new thing now
you can easily do a watch party i'm like
oh [ __ ] yeah
what was your reaction when when all
right well what okay okay obviously no
spoilers in this no no i just want to
know what you're i just want to know
what your reaction was
when the credits started when the
credits started wrong i'm sorry i just i
just need to gush i just need to go i've
i think that might be the first time in
my life where the term
dumbfounded
is like actually eligible because like i
think if you had if i had seen myself in
the cinemas right i probably would have
made a face light
for the entire credits just because uh
because my brain i don't think could
process what the [ __ ] i just watch
and like and because i went to go see
with uh ken camiarto who was on the show
right um and uh he was obviously you
know during the credit sequence he was
just like oh i know that animator
meanwhile like what ken was saying was
just going in one ear and out the other
yeah i was like ken don't give me more
information i'm still trying to process
everything i literally just watched yeah
and uh yeah i don't know like it was i
think the best way to describe 4.0 for
me was it was very bittersweet yeah
because it's like you've it's it's not
until really those credits end and you
walk out of the cinemas yeah you realize
oh this is really it yeah like i'm there
there isn't going to be another movie
anymore yeah i mean maybe there will be
maybe maybe there'll be a spin-off story
this movie franchise has ended like
something i [ __ ] grew up with my
whole life yeah and like i don't know i
was like is this how i'm going to feel
when like one piece ends or like that's
how i felt when arthur got cancelled
i don't i don't even want i can't
believe they cancelled off yeah oh they
got cancelled oh they've got
pennsylvania oh they got cancelled
when like like right after the episode
where i said arthur will never be
cancelled
it literally got cancelled oh my god no
i just assumed arthur was going to be
there when i had like children yeah [ __ ]
man yeah so like i don't know like i
feel this is how because i've obviously
never experienced like a show i grew up
with like a big big franchise like that
to just end in my lifetime right like i
feel this is how it's gonna be when like
one piece or like jojo or like i don't
even wanna imagine when one piece and
jojo were yeah right like i feel like
that emotion that i felt at the end of
4.0 is how i'm going to feel and it's uh
it's not a great feeling it was like
because because it's her own life now
that i watch something and i feel
something i've never felt before which
is which is exactly what i felt because
this is something i grew up with
something i always thought would be
there right yeah and then it's just it's
just like it's just over and really does
feel like like a family pet has just
died yeah you know it's like it's
something that it really is it's like
i'm i'm like it's honestly it's that
same amount
i started [ __ ] balling about it
because like here's the thing here's the
thing right his thing i wasn't even
hyped for 4.0 yeah right because like
[ __ ] nine years had passed since the
fast since the last film and i'm just
like i'm i'm just like whatever it's out
i will i'll watch it out of obligation i
love ava but i don't i could go my
entire life without watching another
avant garde movie and i would have been
completely satisfied so i watched it
literally out of obligation yeah and
then like i think the last half hour hit
and i'm just like oh my god what is this
i'm feeling right now is this is this a
feeling of closure am i am i closing a
page in my life right now i'm just like
what is what is this feeling and then
the end credits fell like the end
credits started rolling and i just
process is the right word because there
are so many emotions coming up at once
that i just i didn't know how to process
them all yeah and you just felt empty
and you just just felt like i i felt
like a
[ __ ] void in my life and i'm just
like
there is nothing that's going to fill
this hole up there
that's why i need to talk about it
that's why i'm so desperate to because
because i remember as well like when the
when the first posters for 4.0 got
released in japan the tagline for it was
sayonara evangelion which means goodbye
evangelion and i was like okay that's
kind of a cool
very you know like
very like artistic like
kind of tagline i didn't think anything
over right yeah but then when they said
that line in the movie at that at a
particular scene i was like
no
don't do this to me man don't leave me
i'm sorry i should have treated you
better i should have treated you man i
should have treated you more more right
don't leave me not now
and like that was the moment where i was
like oh okay like this that point i
think really solidified to me how
important this series was to me i'd
forgotten it was until until that moment
and like i've been doing ever since i've
ever since that movie i could i've not
been able to watch anything else i'm not
able to play
i just feel like the emptiness you
literally can't you literally can't
consume any other media for at least a
week because like i tried to and i'm
just like this the same this ain't ava
this is the same they say neighbor well
what's the point i'm really scared to
re-watch it yeah i tried to try playing
a game of league lost i'm just like
don't care whatever is that how it felt
the ending
i'm just like i'm just like nothing's
gonna fill this it's like that moment
after you come you just don't feel
anything
you just said you just sit there like
what i'm saying right now
i think i've just reached zen yeah like
i i feel like i'm reach i've reached
enlightenment like like [ __ ] being a
monk man like this is this what it feels
like you just you just like you're just
like an open book and you're just like
i've i finally who would have thought i
could become a monk with a 6.99 i
remember
so for anyone watching this who's never
seen ava we're not we're not coming onto
here saying that we recommend you to
watch ava it's it's hard to recommend
something it's hard to recommend now
because you're not going to have the
same experience that we had where you
just like where you grew up with this so
and you know like i said it's it if
you're someone who's going in a tough
time in your life then i honestly
recommend you experience it because
maybe i will teach you something about
yourself i did i was going to say i was
like do you you know if you haven't had
any struggles with mental health is it
hard to appreciate stuff like that i
think so i think so because like i
because like after watching i've like
i've just been binge watching so many
like ava analysis like videos which is
which is like which is like i guess like
my way of coping i think i think ken and
i had about a six hour conversation and
it is a kayak about just the movie we
just watched the entire time yeah and i
think the uh video that that i like
related to the most in terms of what i
felt when i watched the first time was
uh
it was ava bridge
scout scamboli like scam early reviews
did a video called you don't understand
ava
like in like sarcastic text you know
where uh where he basically broke down
why ava is like basically a really badly
told plot and really like
like he he basically broke it down in a
way where i completely agreed with him
oh i would have completely agreed with
him because that was basically that was
basically what i was trying to say when
i watched the first time yeah yeah i
just didn't
resonate or relate to anything that was
trying to me neither i i i you know i
didn't really feel sorry for shinji at
all i felt like i was supposed to yeah
but i was like that's the thing the
emotions were there i mean the execution
was not there i mean like i don't think
like you were even supposed to feel
sorry for him right because yeah exactly
i'd like either you do feel sorry for
him or you don't like a lot of people
would do because a lot of people relate
to that kind of mental space right they
can resonate with that but like the
series doesn't explicitly tell you you
should feel sorry for this person this
person is this it's just that's that's
that's kind of like that's kind of like
the thing that maybe like
no not everyone will enjoy ava not
everyone should enjoy it i mean i i
wouldn't recommend it to someone in a
very healthy mental state because one
you probably wouldn't get it into i
wouldn't wish for you to be in a bad
mental state to begin with yeah get it
right yeah but i i mean you know bojack
i thought was great because i i wasn't
depressed watching it but i certainly
was after oh yeah but i mean like things
like bojack and like you know we we
related ava to bojack but i think like
something like oyster boom boom is
probably closer in terms of like
actually you know presenting a very sad
story in a way that can get anyone of
any mental state you know invested in
the story of bojack right like you know
bojack in that case was told in a very
like straightforward like here's the
thing that's [ __ ] up you know this is
why you should feel sorry and for most
people they felt sorry
but like i feel ava in that sense is
almost
so vague with what you what they want
the viewer to feel yeah to the point
where it's like here are the emotions
that you should be feeling but we're not
going to tell you to feel those emotions
specifically that's up to you to decide
yeah kind of thing like i i don't trust
anyone who says they understand ava like
no like you you can you can spend
all like well it just sounds like you
can have an interpretation of it you can
have an entertainer
but
i honestly don't think it's possible i'm
sure there are some ava fans that are
out there that are just like i can't
believe you said that i'm actually
but like i've like spent so many [ __ ]
hours watching different people analyze
it different people's interpretation but
like there are so many different
interpretations of the series to begin
with that i i just think that's that's
that's the thing right there's a reason
why we are still discussing it to this
day 26 years later yeah and i think
it'll always be disgusting
i remember it was a couple of years ago
i think like uh when when we were still
in the rush of all these people you know
just analyzing every single piece of
imagery from the tv series right and one
that got discussed a lot was when the
angels explode they created an explosion
that looks like a cross yeah and there
was i watched so many analysis videos
being like this is why arno chose the
cross and why it's super symbolic and
blah blah blah then a couple of years
later they came out with an interview
with arno and they were asking so uh is
there any reason why when the angels
explodes it turns into a cross and he
literally just said i just think it
looks cool
it doesn't mean anything i mean all the
anime youtube's like
we spent all this time analyzing
something
that he just put in because it looked
cool
and like and i feel like that alone to
me
really showed the fact that anno doesn't
think this [ __ ] is deep he just put it
in because it's cool so if you're saying
that you didn't have time or money to
make a proper ending yeah yeah what's
the odds that he had the time to be able
to be like no no change the explosion to
across yeah yeah like this this is why
you should do this because it's symbolic
to the story no because
it's just a love letter to all the [ __ ]
that arnold likes he's like i think the
cross looks cool let's add that [ __ ] in
yeah yeah i mean at the same time i
would say that maybe he didn't make a
conscious choice he put stuff in just
because it felt right it doesn't look
right and it created a certain tone a
certain mood whatever especially in four
people you can analyze that but to say
that everything had a purpose and
everything was put there for a reason i
think i think no no not everything
i i don't think anna knew everything
that he knew what he wanted to say
especially in 4.0 as well there was so
much [ __ ] in there i'm like that doesn't
make any
sense that doesn't that why is that
there oh [ __ ] it you know what it's on i
just let him do what he wants to do yeah
i guess like moving on from like ava as
a franchise we can we can we can like
tag you back in now corner we can tag
you back in
like has there been any other like
points or like series or franchise where
you've kind of like grown up with that
franchise and and
you've had like you've seen the
franchise come back years and years
later and you've it's you view it
differently as an adult as opposed to
when you saw it as a kid because i
remember the first time it happened to
me was remember when toy story 3 got rid
of i was literally thinking toy story
when you said that yeah yeah yeah i feel
that's the only thing that's like stuck
around right i think there's been two
has been toy story 3 and american pie
reunion right
huh what i can't relate to the ladder
unfortunately yeah i i think american
pie was like because like when american
when american pie one and two got
released it was [ __ ] massive during
not even like my generations but i think
like i really saw american pie because
it was like my older cousin's generation
they would like put it on tv and i'm
just like
there's those [ __ ] boobs on
what the [ __ ] going on here like
like is
[Music]
i remember i remember watching like
because that's how i experienced
american pie one and two and it was
[ __ ] massive and then seeing american
power reunion and just seeing everyone
as just like
responsible adults and just like being i
don't even
know what that's about yeah having like
children like because they they they
have a high school union and you see
these characters and they're one they're
like a lot older yeah and people have
jobs and they have children and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] is this what the
what's what's that what's happened to my
childhood no no no it's like it's like a
real high school review you see it
everyone's still in uni right everyone's
sitting still getting pissed and
partying right i'm pretty sure i saw uh
his dad she knows dad in american pie
yeah he's in every movie yeah pretty
sure i just saw him in canada when i was
on like the ski lift
i sat next to him i'm near certain i did
he spoke to me as well and he had the
exact same voice but i couldn't exactly
see his face he's wearing ski stuff
he looked like it and i was like i think
this is him
you should have just been like are you
the dad from american games i was like i
wasn't sure and imagine if he wasn't
he'd be like what the [ __ ] is that yeah
yeah well no then you could have spotted
being like you sound just like him i'm
near certain it's him but i was like 14
so i didn't want to all right
i swear i swear it's [ __ ] how do you
remember that [ __ ] because i literally
just reminded me and i remember getting
off the scooter thinking like
was it
so the guy from see like these [ __ ]
bushy
of course that's the
that's the one thing i remember
yeah same skin tone the voice was like
spot-on
what the [ __ ]
is this
no but like uh yeah well i mean have you
seen all the toy stories i haven't seen
toy story before good i was i was like
toy story thought toy story 3 was my ava
four point yeah you know where where
where like
what no no no no way i watched it and
i'm just like that was a nice send off
to your stories yeah and then they made
a fourth one yeah
don't bother watching three i didn't
really like three i i didn't like it so
much i i liked i like it felt special to
me because it felt like you know i was
saying
the end
[Laughter]
we're just like seeing andy grow up and
seeing
um i'm sorry yeah i mean i mean we need
like a toy story like 1.0 yeah
what what is the plot of toy story for
why is there anything they go like the
circus i don't even i've not haven't
even watched it so i saw toy story for
in cinemas
because it was available i went to go
see with aki just because we were like
we want to go to the cinemas what's
playing right now oh toy story 4 is
there all right let's go watch it
because at that point i hadn't heard
anything about it
so let's go
yeah it uh it [ __ ] sucks it really
does suck i mean the movie is decent but
literally the last 15 minutes of that
movie not only ruin the movie but just
completely ruin the entirety of the toy
story franchise yeah i heard it broke a
lot of the rules and also it kind of
like ruined woody's character yeah it
completely destroyed every character and
it just ends off with like this well
woody's on the road now also not that
invested in the cast of toy story so if
you know if buzz commits war crimes i'm
not really gonna care that much i'm just
gonna be like all right well i mean he
shouldn't have bombed that but i mean
like at least at least toy story 3 right
obviously not going to spoilers but at
least toy story 3. you could spoil toy
story theory really i think it's okay i
don't know there might be people like i
can't believe this is not even four
points
i can't believe they ruined the ending
of toy story spoiled
all right well okay well like with toy
story for three like like you know that
scene where woody's like so long partner
like that that's it yeah yeah like that
was like really [ __ ] nice like that
that made me tear up a little bit i just
didn't like the fuzz bear uh the care
bear villain i just did i i was like
well i mean at least it didn't last
right yeah i guess so it didn't last i
think the scene that stuck out to me
what's with toy story three if we're
getting into spoiler territory
yeah the incinerator oh yeah of course
[ __ ] what i hated that scene what what
it just dragged on and you knew what was
gonna happen it was like all right come
on
all right
what are you a [ __ ] movie critic
right now
well did you think they should have died
yeah i would have it would have been
nice
actually that was the alternative
universe of you know that would have
truly ruined toy story we saw like 20
000 buzzes in like toy story 2 why
couldn't we have like spanish buzz take
over you know
what's why why buzz
i'll tell you who would have killed off
the toy story cast hidden akiano
yeah he would have killed them
they're all toys
they go into the incinerator and then
they explode in a giant cross
they would have melted and been deformed
well yeah of course also what year is
this where we have incinerators attached
to like kindergartens or whatever what
that is true who installed an
incinerator in a kindergarten how how
irresponsible is this why was that there
don't go anywhere in children
wait what was this
in the kindergarten like completely
nearby right or something i'm pretty
sure it was nearby or something i don't
know what what why i just
didn't didn't they go to a garbage dump
i don't [ __ ] know yeah they went to
yeah that's right
i just thought it was attached to like
the school
the kindergarten that would have been
the real plots
it had been like it was actually a
disposal site all along it was not a
kindergarten i don't know kind of just
[ __ ] mementoed himself where like he
just like
you [ __ ] king crimson yourself where
like a time period just [ __ ]
disappeared you're like i guess they
just ended up in a [ __ ] generator i
was so bored at that point in the movie
because one and two i liked a lot i
liked that a lot i love the scenery he's
like oh i gotta drive to work and then
he crosses the street yeah that scene
was a bang that's a classic that's a
glass i love that just naming off memes
now toy story one and two are actually
like really [ __ ] funny can i just say
toy story two that scene at the airport
is still one of my favorites toy story
that scene that fight scene can i call
it a fight yeah yeah
yeah that that uh that score that that
squabble scene
i felt you know a lot of the modern uh
uh i can watch a lot of the older films
that i haven't even watched before kids
ones and i thought that they're really
good because they just you know they're
as an adult you can watch them no
problem but i find that when i watch a
lot of the new uh kids films i can't i
can't watch them because they're just
oh you're talking about like recent
pixar films and stuff like that yeah i
feel like they've been like i mean this
is a common thing right whether
everyone's like oh they've been dumbed
down but i did feel that like uh when i
watched a lot of the older movies
like disney
uh like 80s to 2000s like i can watch
any of them like this is good but i
can't watch them as well i mean like i
did have like a period where i actually
sat down and like watched all of like
the recent disney movies and the recent
pixar movies because i wanted to make
sure right i was like is it actually
getting dumbed down or is that just like
my
like own opinion you watch pinocchio
that movie's [ __ ] yeah that yeah that
movie is i do not remember pinocchio
have you watched pinocchio
i know i have they
they smoke cigars they turn into donkeys
they smoke cigars gamble and drink
alcohol yeah like and i'm like and these
are like these like these kids are like
eight years old i don't remember woody
like cracking open a bong like
you know what i mean
you're gonna hit the ball
and he's in college hit the bong
i know it's huge
pretty sure that's just [ __ ] sausage
party i'm pretty sure this is actually
like uh the playboy magazine comes to
life this is like a cartoon robot
chicken uh yeah
it's like a new ground spinning
pretty sure this is a thing i don't know
yeah wait there yeah there was a
robot chicken where like they go to am i
am i dreaming this where they're like
they do a toy story parody like dildos
talk or something
i don't know
that's a million dollars maybe i've made
this up
that's all yours i mean that's slow
hanging through but i i feel i feel like
that sounds like a fever dream but most
robot chicken skits are adults
i can't remember what i've made up and
what is actually happening and what has
happened i shouldn't share too much man
you're giving away million dollar ideas
left and right maybe the thing is i'll
have this idea oh it's already been done
it was never done
until it wasn't i have an absolutely
abhorrent memory i'm just absolutely
abysmal when it comes to remembering
films and media i just can't i remember
what i remember jojo and that's pretty
much it i don't know what i felt about
the media i don't remember much about it
just like one or two scenes here and
there that's all i remember i i think
that's pretty common though is that
common well i i think especially if you
can't remember character names either
well i think i'm i'm also shooting yeah
but i feel that's especially the case
for people who have consumed like a
shitload of media right like after a
while like your brain's gonna overcap
with that kind of [ __ ] yeah i'm just the
modern day problem of too much too much
medium too much consumption too much
media i can't remember [ __ ] anything
now i'm watching youtube shorts and i
feel like my brain has like one second
memory
yeah tick-tock in the shorts definitely
haven't helped in hacking your brain to
be like okay on to the next thing but
consume consume consume but then i
talked to my dad and he like can't
remember the word for anything and i'm
like [ __ ] is that what i'm gonna be like
i think that's a different problem
he's just like he just refuses to learn
like the if you if he's learnt a word a
certain way he just will never correct
it like what do you mean like like he's
he um like pronouncing or like yeah
pronunciation yeah he he will never
change the pronunciation once he's
decided what the pronunciation is in his
head i don't think that's a memory issue
i think that's just being stubborn but i
think that is like an older thing
because i think i've met a few other
people who do that whether you're like
you you correct the pronunciation like
no oh no my dad is like that as well my
dad's like he tells a fact and then i go
um actually it's not and then he's like
no no no honestly i'm not a credible
source i'm kind of like that yeah i know
are you going to tell me that gif is not
pronounced gif it is gif i i don't give
a [ __ ] he says
that's the point i don't give a [ __ ] if
that guy says he's jiff yeah yeah i
don't give a [ __ ] it's gift it's gif and
like [ __ ] the world could end and
like don't have a say even though you
made it yeah
the g stands for graphic you don't say
graphic
no exactly sound it's gif
like they could be like like there could
be a gun to my head to be like you can
live if you just say jiff and be like no
shoot me now
i'll take the gun off him
i don't know you know even if you made
the thing i think you can have you know
if if you made it a clear from the start
that it was that and that's what it was
but it became massive public domain
and was widely used before
it became into the public discourse that
it was called jif right right so at that
point no he might have been saying it
for a while but he didn't do a very good
job of making everyone know it was jif
he should everything at the bottom
should have a watermark saying it is
pronounced gif yeah
to make it clear
but i feel like as a creator you don't
really have much uh say over how no no
especially when it becomes that
widespread yeah it's already like rooted
into society there are so many things
that like once they're adopted by the
public you know you they become their
own kind of beast right it becomes its
own thing yeah and you don't really get
a sale price well that's like if you
know arno came out tomorrow and said
it's actually pronounced evangelion
no it's not
it's it's invention yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah i mean okay i know i mean i
know something it's like jk rowling
telling us like weird harry potter facts
like like they just [ __ ] they [ __ ]
themselves and then teleport it away
what was the other weird one that he
brought out like something weird about
hagrid or something
it was dumbledore's gays dumbledore
but that's canon yeah that was already
canonical there was another one with
like hagrid where it was like something
really [ __ ] weird about yeah i can't
remember and i was like
it was like
hagrid had a [ __ ] threesome
i was just like
what are you doing jk rowling why are
you doing this
it happens in between the first two
balls
if you do try and retcon things or what
it feels like retconning the audience
will be like no
yeah i mean i mean yeah i mean anna's
done that several [ __ ] times because
he's he's come out several times saying
like no it's it's not like that like for
example the crosses the
cross doesn't mean anything the cross
doesn't mean anything although i just
put this in because i thought it was
cool and then yeah i guess so i guess it
comes and people are like no no no no
but then that's interesting right
because then that takes the argument of
it's not whether as much as it's not
really anything to do with the media
itself it's more so to do with what the
public likes you and like it's like
okay you've got to point out that it's
true it's it's whether or not the public
actually takes you out yeah it's whether
or not the public actually takes you
seriously so like even if she released a
new book i'm sure people will be like
nah it's not carnival i just don't like
her
well sometimes you sometimes you just
got to decide you know and also i think
i think she has pushed it with what she
can get the audience to agree with yeah
yeah oh yeah i think once you've brought
in these characters and you've brought
in this world there's a certain amount
of uh no i don't i don't really agree
with that yeah like i mean she certainly
hasn't helped her public image with that
kind of stuff right meanwhile if like
[ __ ] nasu came out with another faith
thing was like uh yes this is actually
not canonical all the nice fans will be
like yes thank you nasu thank you for
another piece
was uh did it was anno ever ridiculous
with the stuff that he suggested have
you seen
yeah but like it's all it's all always
in line you know
hearing is the definition of ridiculous
harry potter had rules to some extent
yeah and to hear her go yeah oh the
reason why hagrid doesn't have kids is
because he exclusively fists people
that's not
that isn't just something that he's
incapable of reproducing
you know that doesn't line up with what
i understood about
her
just say that it's like okay
uh
no i don't know about that
that's what that was the level of absurd
is that jk rowling would bring to the
top oh my god i wish that was canon
i actually wish i don't know
i mean it's not as any more ridiculous
than like taking a [ __ ] and making it
disappear
magical
like love that i also think that's
amazing why wasn't that in the movie
like like i was like sometimes sometimes
like i think sometimes as an author and
as a consumer you've got to understand
you've got to think sometimes at what
point is there too much detail in yeah
that's the exact point when there's too
much [ __ ] speed
i just loved that
jk rowling thought about this after the
fact i thought that's a neat little fan
yeah i would let everyone know
this also makes me wonder was just like
were they just [ __ ] fascinated when
they first saw a toilet in like the
human world they're like holy [ __ ] you
have a room dedicated for [ __ ]
this is amazing
like you know do they wipe like
do they do they have does that get
teleported as well
by that sense you'd never need a shower
because every single thing attached to
your body including some this you know
well does it get teleported while it's
inside of it no no i think i think i
think what i remember from the tweet
that she did i think you take a [ __ ] and
then they don't teleport it anywhere
they just make it invisible
i think
oh they magic away the evidence that's
magical what about you what does that
mean
that's so many interpretations magic
away the evidence i i need a five-page
thesis i don't know like a 10-20 page
thesis i did like a six-hour video on
that like the position on your ass
though still like it's not clean you
need a bidet or something or i assume
does the spell get rid of that if so
then why would you need to ever shower
because surely the spell can also get
rid of any bodily fluids or odor that
you might have also you know when they
not and if they're inside of someone
they don't want to get them pregnant do
they just like delete us yeah
[Laughter]
oh my
god are they able to cast spells if they
if they okay okay i i believe right i'm
on board with i'm on board with the fact
that you can you can spell away your own
fluids right in your own body if you if
you get your fluids in someone else's
body can your spells still get them away
does that does it can you can you get
rid of fluids in other people's bodies i
just like to imagine like [ __ ]
i want to say that next time i'm not
it's like baby where's the condom pulls
out a wand
things you should never say after sex
fetus are we 10 years old here
i'm sorry
jk can you please make that [ __ ]
cannon please
that's information i want to know about
the harry potter universe
yeah i don't i don't care about the
disappearing [ __ ] i care about what they
do to replace condoms in the harry
potter wall oh god i'm not gonna be able
to get that image out of my mind
i was having a rant and i would just
like off in my own world
it's like pointing the wall down
i got you babe oh
sorry what are we talking about
do you want to repeat your rant
if you can get rid of the fluids yeah
yeah
excrement
if you nut in somebody else yeah can you
get rid of their fluids because it's
technically inside of them
this is a very disgusting uh
conversation about one that needs to be
done it's fascinating it's fascinating
thank you thank you jk rowling thank you
jk for uh
for letting our imagination run wild
yeah for aunt for asking the important
questions and answering the importance i
still can't get over the [ __ ] like
what was it deleting the evidence with
magic or some [ __ ] yeah yeah whose own
words vanished the evidence vanish the
evidence with magic that's what i'm
going to say in court next time when i
commit a murder
uh your honor i vanished the evidence
with magic moving on another of moving
excrement i've been moving my stuff
you've been moving your shoes you've
been moving period right yeah it's been
moving house oh my god
so long yeah how's how's that been going
for you
very long
i mean people people on twitter were
asking and people coming into my streams
being like colonel's not streaming right
now everyone's like he hasn't streamed
for like 10 days i miss it
kind of like no subs when i come back
yeah so sad have to work from the ground
up again but like you're pretty much
fully moved in right like you're out of
your room yeah i've i fully moved like a
week ago but then i went away for like
five days as well
and also i didn't have any furniture and
then it all came and it's taking up all
of my living room so like building stuff
is such a nightmare yeah got like jenga
stuff out of the way and then build it
but then it takes up a lot of room
because the boxes obviously were tightly
packed yeah you got to like move the box
in another room right here yeah yeah so
it's like every time i feel like i make
any progress something else turns up
that i got to do and i'm like
i just have a bed now oh yeah it's a
nice bed well you got the koala because
yeah yeah yeah yeah i did yeah like
taking care of all the [ __ ] cardboard
that's been building oh my god yeah
because you know in the uk you could
just you know fill up your car yeah
drive down to the local recycling center
and chuck all the cardboard yeah yeah
pretty pretty easy really yeah but in
japan you can't do that you have to put
it in your you recycle it in your
building and actually on a specific day
actually you might be able to take it um
somewhere but i don't have a car yeah
and also i'm not renting a car just to
take cardboard but luckily the new place
i moved into you can just put them out
at any time oh that's good and there's
like a whole area for trash downstairs
like an inside area yes my previous
place it was put outside yeah so you
could only put it on like wednesday at 8
00 a.m yeah my current place is like
that as well yeah i hated that because i
was like [ __ ] dude i got [ __ ] to do man
see my place though it says you need to
take everything out before 8 a.m
at my place they don't come to pick it
up till like 2 p.m yeah oh yeah they did
that too yeah so i'm just like i'll just
[ __ ] take it out in the morning
they used to in my old place they i when
i first moved in they were like you have
to wake up at 7 00 am to take up the
trash yeah i'm waking up at 7 00. i'll
stay up till like 4 a.m and do it yeah
yeah
waking up with seven and [ __ ] off yeah
like are you serious i mean it's gotten
me to like get a good sleep schedule at
least like i wake up nice and early in
the morning to get [ __ ] done but that's
not a good thing to wake up yeah yeah
well yeah oh yeah wake up i can't wait
to go [ __ ] take out my smelly garbage
you get used to it after a while
honestly but then uh yeah the new place
is great you can just chuck it out
anytime there's like normally the the
more
modern apartment buildings you can just
like
go downstairs and there'll be an area
yeah our old our old office had that
yeah yeah because it wasn't you were
building yeah the trash station was
super good it was it's basically like
that it's like identical right um but
there's like a separate room for like
stinky trash i guess
like burnable yeah
yeah so there's just like another room
for that i mean i guess that's good
right like because you know you don't
have to [ __ ] your nose don't have to
struggle when you take cardboard out
right it's so weird though there's like
my room has like this really like
massive security camera that points at
the trash and i'm guessing it's to stop
uh you from doing anything strange right
like putting trash that you shouldn't
yeah and there is literally like black
and white tape all over this room like
it looks like a murder room and i think
it's on purpose to scare you right to
make you not feel like you're it's okay
to like whatever you do
i think trashing stuff you shouldn't be
trashing there
are like weirdos
burnable stuff right in japan yeah it's
very specific so like plastic bottles
can't go with plastic yeah it has to
very specifically go with plastic
bottles yeah there's a whole nother area
for that yeah and there's pl and
cardboard can't go with paper paper is
another thing and paper is burnable yeah
it's no no it's it's in my place it's
not all right
it's recyclable oh yeah yeah some places
it's burnable but also depends on the
size of the paper if it's too small it's
not you can't put it in the thing it's
really [ __ ] weird there are so many
rules and you most of them you have to
follow and all of these rules as well
changes depending on where you are yeah
yeah you can live in the same you can
live in tokyo but every municipality in
tokyo has a different rule
and like you know so also like batteries
is very specific you can only go in a
certain place so all this stuff is very
confusing um and and there should be no
matter where you live in tokyo or
saitama or chiba or any of those places
there should be an english guide yeah
yeah you normally all have that you
usually get an english guide at the town
hall when you move in yeah it's very
confusing because sometimes the material
isn't covered so like cardboard is good
but cardboard pizza boxes no no no
because it's been greasy yeah yeah can't
go i actually have an app yeah that
where if i type in a certain thing then
it tells me what day to take it out
so if i'm not sure then i go to my app i
type in you know like yeah because i
remember one time it was like uh there
was like a specific type of styrofoam
it's not like the it's not like the hard
like squeaky styrofoam it's nice
so i was like [ __ ] i don't know what
that is so i looked it up on the app and
it was on a completely different day i
was like oh thank god wait really yeah i
put that in vulnerable well i don't know
maybe my municipal is different
styrofoam is just the one thing when i'm
just like where does this go i'm just
like styrofoam is portable right some
some types of styrofoam is burnable
it was recyclable plastics
it completely changes where you are yeah
sometimes it's all burnable
i just put like eight bags of that [ __ ]
sometimes it's all burnable sometimes
it's gonna knock on your door the police
are gonna come in and just like so
excuse me are you the that threw out all
of those styrofoam
they're just having a haunch imagine
being the guy
just like throughout all the burnables
in the wrong place there's a lot of
foreigners in my building as well so
it's like i don't feel like the odd one
out i definitely felt like my old
building it was for japanese families oh
yeah
well you were living in an area that was
very like oh yeah not not exactly like
gaijin friendly
we all because we all lived five minutes
away from each other yeah back in the
day and i lived even further out than
you guys yeah
i definitely lived with like all like
the um and in a relatively older
building as well oh yeah it was super
old yeah and uh it was definitely a
family building as well i don't know and
i didn't see anyone else there who
looked even remotely my age yeah yeah uh
they were nice though i never really had
any problem actually i got a i got a
noise complaint but i expected this
match yeah well i mean if you're
shouting at [ __ ] two ways
sorry it's one of those things
when i first moved in i would literally
walk around my own apartment like metal
gear solid like i was so s because i'd
heard nightmare scenarios about noise
where i was just tiptoeing around my
apartment like at night because i
genuinely thought if i just walked at a
normal brisk pace yeah i would get like
shouted out
but you know the months go on and you
start to realize you know okay okay i
guess i can't help the clapping of my
ass cheeks because you're so loud i'm so
dummy thick tommy thing you know then
one time i had friends over who stayed
over till five and i never got a noise
complaint and then i was like oh okay
and then you slowly get more comfortable
you test the limit yeah because you know
and then maybe something happened where
all right there's a deadline i have to
record this thing it's 2am and they need
it right now yeah okay well i guess i'll
do it i'll just scream one line then
i'll do it and then also i had to record
voice lines one time i'd i distinctly
remember were full-on shouting yeah but
this was like mid-day yeah but it was to
the point where i was this is shouting
so loud and so aggressively that i i
would totally understand if the police
were called right in any scenario it
sounded like a murder was happening
literally even a murderer wouldn't have
done it with such conviction the way i
did so i was i did that and then
definitely more confident so it's one of
those things where i just built up and
then i started streaming and i started
streaming later yeah and later and later
and then i started streaming louder and
louder and then eventually i got a noise
complaint yeah which was totally because
i think it was one where i was totally
screaming at 4am which i totally
understood i just assumed the people
below me because this was a four bedroom
i just assumed they were sleeping in a
totally different room and they were so
old that they nothing would wake them up
i was hoping that they were that kind of
old people where they were they were not
getting up for anything yeah that's the
thing sometimes like you get lucky
because like the the room that if you
especially if you have multiple rooms
the room that you scream the loudest
yeah is nowhere near where the person
downstairs is sleeping yeah it's it's
always it's mostly like where is the
bedroom located yeah and am i making a
lot of noise where their bedroom is
located because anywhere else i feel
like it's they're they're more
understanding about it but it's always
the bedroom yeah and i think like i
really lucked out with the apartment i
had before because i've never got a
noise complaint and i'm very lucky i
don't know how you yeah i feel like i
definitely should like i [ __ ] limit
test that thing i i i had parties at
your house
we've had very loud parties at 5 00 a.m
um on a saturday so if we weren't being
completed
it doesn't matter to the old people in
japan
that is not acceptable anywhere but uh
it's uh yeah i [ __ ] limit broke that
[ __ ] and i didn't get a noise complaint
and i'm like very very surprised
saturday's it it doesn't matter what day
of the week it is to an old person like
because like the cops aren't going to be
like all right we got a noise
complaining you'd be like
oh saturday license to party yeah
[Music]
have a nice day i just i just feel like
i i feel like a locked up because i feel
like i had neighbors who had like a
mutual understanding because i feel like
i've had the only neighbor i can
i that i've know of of anyone living in
japan that was like really [ __ ] noisy
yeah um like they would have arguments
all the [ __ ] time it wasn't just like
a japanese argument it was full on
shouting sometimes it was the most
unjapanese japanese argument i've ever
heard right and i'm just like
if if you if you make noise then you
know i'm going to make noise as well
yeah i'm making you want to understand
yeah mutual understanding that's it's a
symbiotic relationship you know
the way i i was always very you know
even if i wasn't making noise i would be
if if they're having a party once a
month yeah
so be it yeah exactly it's once a month
i can live with that it's not like i
have like uh
i don't know like a bonsai tree that's
sensitive to noise or something in my
apartment that shits itself here's two
decibels you know what i mean like i'm
yeah i think it's okay yeah yeah that's
why i wouldn't really call the cops but
japanese people have no chill with that
and they just immediately call the cops
well no because to them it's like why
are you being so loud at home when you
could just go to an izakaya or go out in
town and have fun and i'm like i would
if everything doesn't close at 8pm and
alcohol can't be served yeah one of the
things that's been so
taking so long in my new place is that
my office i've actually like gone
through the whole effort of like trying
to sound treat it to the best of my
ability right as much as you can because
the best way to sound
proof a room is to do it while they're
building the goddamn room yeah
you know but i've had to do it in post
yeah yeah and uh it's been a nightmare
so i've had to put like two layers of
stuff on my wall and then i still
haven't done it all yet um so like two
layers of fabric um that i've attached
to the wall and then i'm doing the third
which is the like sound foam yeah
because you know youtubers just put like
four pieces and they're like it's
soundproof my room and it's like that is
not even remotely soundproof i like the
i like the rooms where it's like one
piece over here and another piece over
here and it's just like it's just one
piece behind where they're sitting yeah
like my job here is
yeah
my limb looks super weird right now
because it's just all like every single
wall is like a black plastic rubber yeah
but it works it's like you can't really
hear me immediately the echo is gone
it's yeah and so i i put uh i put a
layer of the
uh
the rubber stuff down as well and then i
put noise reducing carpet on top of it
so like you can jump in my room
neighbors ain't gonna hear [ __ ]
downstairs yeah i i i actually just
finished like that in my office as well
like finally i i was talking about joey
what i was doing jerry was like that
sounds like a good idea yeah so i
decided to do that my room because my my
room was like super [ __ ] echoey
because i have like wooden floors all
right so immediately
immediately once i put up before i even
started putting up the sound phone
immediately with the carpet it's like
eighty percent of the excess yeah every
single wall you do makes it it gets
better results yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
it's not since i moved to japan that i'm
just like man carpets are good i miss
carpets yeah because like we had carpets
in england like you you didn't have a
like you didn't have a house you never
had a house in england that had wooden
floors right because it's not good for
noise are not noise like oh we have uh
heat insulation no really no living room
is wooden but upstairs was carpet yeah
yeah so the house was like halfway in
like your rooms you'd have carpet yeah i
didn't know how much i missed that until
i moved to asia where everything here is
wooden floors well we had like fitted
carpet in in europe i think where like
they come in and they especially like
get the right size and they fit it all
professionally yeah but in japan they
always use these the square like just
pick up and go okay yeah the post carpet
yeah they just they in japan like a lot
of the carpets are just like you'll see
them everywhere they're just like these
like cubes
yeah they're everywhere like they're
just like squares you plunk them down
and then you just cut them around the
edges so i had to like hand cut it to my
room it looks really [ __ ] good but i
spent like a whole [ __ ] day doing it
yeah i did too because my room's not
square yeah it's like it's like weird
[ __ ] shapes i'm like oh and cutting
the corners and stuff as well in the ass
so like it looks good from a distance
but when you get down on the floor you
see how much of a [ __ ] jump
but that shit's hard man it's hard i'm
very proud of it i've been diying for
like two days yes but it looks great it
looks amazing and when everything's set
up it should be good yeah that'll be me
in like two months yeah because we're i
think i'm the last one to move out
i'm planning to have a whole wall of
just jojo posters i don't know that'll
be like did you have that in your old
place no no no no no no literally
because before you could see the walls i
was gonna make it like oh like like
literally like
90 of the wall is just jojo posters
isn't it already
no but like it had gaps it had gaps i
don't want guests i want it to be
literally it's like looks like
myself
how good of a shot would it be it's like
just behind me it's literally just jojo
that's so bad
the wall is
like the way i attached it to the wall
was like i wasn't sure if it would it
would like be able to hold the posters
because this this rubber stuff that i
got to prevent sound is is [ __ ] heavy
yeah right you bought a roll as well
yeah it is like it's massive it's uh
what is it
10 meters it's a 10 meter roll
by like one meter wide i think one meter
wide 10 meters long and it's 20
kilograms and it is so [ __ ] heavy
yeah put that on your wall yeah exactly
right how
with great difficulty
and so i was concerned i was like the
way i attached it i was like i wonder if
it will stay if i then put posters on it
so before i left for my trip i attached
the posters and i was like hopefully
when i come back my wall will be intact
and it luckily it's intact
yeah should be fine but the poster
frames i have are extremely light
they're like the lightest poster oh yeah
you should be all right yeah should be
fun should be fine hopefully be really
awkward if i'm streaming one day and my
whole world
[ __ ] comes down i feel like the big
test is going to be in summer right or
next summer i'm just going to leave my
ac on because yeah yeah i'm not risking
it really all the time that's what i did
in my in my current place because
you know the electricity bill right if
you have i had like what like 20 grand
of computer equipment in my room and
filming equipment the ac bill to have it
running all all the time is what like
maybe an extra 200 300 bucks for the
whole summer well yeah it depends on how
long you have it on for i guess so for
the summer period just leave it on yeah
i'll pay that much just to have my
equipment be fine yeah humidity [ __ ]
your microphones and cameras and pc
equipment i i would rather just have the
whole room ac20 yeah i'm thinking to
invest in a dehumidifier just to put
around humidifier yeah yeah oh i have a
decent fireplace as like a southeast
asian i'm just like i'm like part of my
part of my soul is dying when i'm here
ac is on 24 7. man ac on dehumidify
there's a setting for dehumidifier yeah
that's true i leave it okay okay okay
what happens if the when the ac
inevitably breaks it's an it's a good ac
it's not braking
didn't your ac brake
yeah one of the other ac is broken but
yeah so what's to say what happened in
your room the other one for two years
was fine i'll deal with it when it
breaks
it'll be down for like three days at
most it's fine right because because
like because like i grew up with like i
grew up with my parents beating into me
that was just like look the world could
be on [ __ ] fire right now but you're
not turning on that ac unless you like
really also really needed to be like
connor's wasting so much electricity
you're not in the room and i'm like
you know i'm saving saving money yeah
he's saving the equipment he's saving
the equipment like the devil could be
raising hell right outside a window and
you're not turning on that ac
so let's go to my mates house since
summer and it's [ __ ] roasting i'm
like why are you like this why do you
hate me i mean the summer this year was
like it's like the devil came back from
hell and planted his ass crack on the
earth like you can if you can withstand
that and you can live in a sauna that's
fine i'm not gonna judge you i'm you can
live in that don't come to my [ __ ]
house and tell me to turn my ac off i
didn't choose to live
like this you i didn't want to live on
hard mode i know i don't need to i'm not
going to
i'm not
[ __ ] off don't come to my house and tell
me that
i'm going to do exactly that i'm going
to do like i'm going to go mom mode and
just be like i can't believe you're
wasting all this electricity oh my god
think of the electricity bill i couldn't
care last year think of the electricity
bill my god listen i've lived like that
i i don't i don't need to live like that
know i made good money
to worry about sorry for your ac man
it's just like oh i'm getting i'm
getting a break sometimes right in the
new place as well they installed like
those industrial ones you have them as
well yeah they're built into this one
right so that looks really modern really
nice lifesaver that it's beautiful yeah
perhaps notice that this ac is not on
it's already cool
yeah i mean it's it's thankfully cooled
down this this week
are we still technically in summer i
don't know we are technically in summer
this like past week we've had this like
rain this torrential rain from this like
cold front coming in from hokkaido
and there's been like flood warnings in
like the greater tokyo area and i'm just
like oh man this typhoon season is
really [ __ ] hot i looked at the news
it's not even a
typhoon it's just rain
how
how is it raining more than a typhoon
right it's just just cause like seasons
in japan just don't make sense to me
like you wake up one day and then japan
just decides okay summer's over we're in
the next season now yeah winter's over
we're in the next season there is no
[ __ ] transition period you wake up
one day and you suddenly go from like
dying in the heat you're like oh you've
got to wear trousers and long shirts now
the statement of japan has four seasons
is the beast lie of the century no it
does not
it has two seasons hot cold or hot
cotton cold or hot that's the only two
seasons because there's there is no in
between you know you know you know how
you go to that one place and someone's
like oh you don't like the weather just
wait five minutes hahaha in japan it's
just like you don't like the season just
wait a few days
it'll change it'll change don't put your
jacket off the country yeah don't put
your jacket away you're gonna need in
about three days
guaranteed
and then there's england right where i
never know what the appropriate way to
dress is in england like if it's summer
do i wear a long sleeve still do i wear
short sleeves do i wear shorts do i
bring a coat with me i'm just like
england's the place where it's always
acceptable to bring a coat yeah just in
case i don't what am i supposed to pack
we're going to england i don't know what
to wear i genuinely don't
do i wear can i get away with shirts do
i have to get a bunch i need to bring
this drip i don't know how much drip dry
how much is drip acceptable in the uk am
i allowed to be dripping
i don't know
yeah because like i like because like
it's just one one place where i go
outside and i'm just like should i bring
a coat with me and the answer is always
yeah yeah yeah you can never really go
wrong with bringing a coat in the uk
yeah in japan i feel like a [ __ ]
clown wanna bring her want to bring her
coat i mean especially this time of year
yeah have you noticed though that like
what you wear in the uk is completely
different to what you would normally
wear here like in terms of like sense of
fashion because i feel like at least
with me like sometimes i wouldn't dress
like this in australia for instance uh
why i don't know because i feel that
like just in general just i don't know
maybe it's just the area that i live in
but like japan i feel has definitely
like put in like a different sense of
fashion into me than back in australia
like it to me in australia fashion was
t-shirt shorts sandals
yeah i mean that's australia right yeah
i mean that was like that's that was
like that was like isn't it the national
motto yeah it's like it's like you you'd
feel fancy if you wore a pair of jeans
you know like it's like that little
right but here it's like i don't know i
i feel weird going out with t-shirt
shorts and sandals i mean i think i
think it's just living in a country
that's permanently in summer right
because because like that's kind of me
in thailand where if i'm not wearing
t-shirts shorts and sandals something
special is happening like so it's like
there's like in in england you look for
any opportunity you can to wear shorts
in thailand you look for any opportunity
you can to wear jeans and long sleeves i
want to wear jeans i don't really like
wearing shorts yeah i i don't really
feel comfortable in them why i don't
know i just like exposing you maybe i
haven't found the right pair yes you
know when you sit on i feel like i'm
like how short of shorts are you wearing
though no reasonably sized
i feel like i can't enjoy every service
you know when you sit down on some
things wearing shorts oh gosh don't like
all my skin touches this jeez well i
like what about like three quarter pants
oh there's a bit strange on there yeah
see like it's weird like something like
three quarter pants is completely normal
here but i would feel super [ __ ]
weird if i wore three quarter pants in
australia and it's not because of like
the weather it's just because like i
wouldn't see anyone in australia just
fashion wise wearing three quarter
pieces i i just i just don't think
shorts look very good like like they no
no no okay so so this one looks good in
short
no one looks better in shorts than they
would wearing like jeans okay yeah okay
because like it's it's sunny outside
okay so people can look good on the
beach or whatever in shorts or whatever
anytime you go inside you sit down in
the restaurant you look like a [ __ ]
clown that there is no exception to not
looking like a clown when you go inside
and you're and you're wearing shorts
like they're like i'm watching like the
trash taste off the dark screen and i'm
just like [ __ ] hell our legs look so
ugly like
the knees on knees yeah there's just
there's just so many knees man like too
much skin going on and if it's just like
the three quarter pants well you just
like at that point you just have
commitment issues just commit to shorts
or commit to jeans like like please come
on that's just
like yeah i think being being uh from
the uk i feel like fashion was never a
high priority well yeah and i feel and i
feel in the same way with australia as
well like i feel just i never even
thought about what i was wearing in
australia because i look around me and
i'm like i don't really see anyone who's
like fashionable people are so much
[ __ ] drippier it's insane yeah
people will like be going to work and
they'll be dressed like a [ __ ] model
and that's and i feel that's why i
almost not so much pressured but i guess
like i kind of that made me look at
myself i feel like
bro i mean i i feel like london was
pretty fashionable london oh everyone
dressed the same i feel really everyone
everyone dresses the same i feel in
london i feel like like i i would say
that even maybe people in london have
even more drip than people here in tokyo
i i that's that's my genuine opinion you
see so much like you see
[Music]
why can we not agree over [ __ ] london
you like you like the architecture
[ __ ] hater i i i think you love it
right
i think london's a fashionable city you
look at like uh [ __ ] primark or
anything the models everyone [ __ ]
dress what the [ __ ] you talking about
primark slaps like four four four the
for what you get for the price the
primark fashion which is [ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] child labor you can get some
good clothes you know that's right
probably promoting i remember one time i
bought ten t-shirts for eight pounds in
primark and i thought [ __ ] hell who
made a deal with the devil here why was
this price able to go through i bought
i've bought one thing at primark and it
was a pair of eight sonic the hedgehog
socks
for five pounds that's way that's
overpriced what the [ __ ] five pounds you
got mugged off they're like one pounds
for each yeah but i'm like i bought a
whole suit from primark for like 30 quid
and i'm like
what the [ __ ] what happened and it
looked it looked decent right it looked
decent that's the problem it looked
[Laughter]
what do good mean that's the problem i i
i think now i'm like you know we we paid
what like [ __ ] 70 pounds for a
t-shirt no 70 dollars for t-shirts i
want 40 pounds for a t-shirt
i now feel that you know maybe it's
because i have more money now
maybe it's because i'm not i'm doing
much better for myself i feel that huh i
think i would rather pay 30 40 for a
very good t-shirt as opposed to eight
dollars for ten t-shirts yeah yeah but
like that's that's that's the thing the
biggest thing i've i've noticed
something's gone wrong i i feel like the
biggest difference since moving to japan
is that there were just more affordable
options in high street and in high
streets in the uk but how much how much
affordable is like we're cutting some
severe human rights corners here well
i'm no this is this is like i mean
that's that's going to a different topic
we're talking about drip right and
people having drip i feel like
especially in london a lot of people
have the drip comes with a costco
you look here and basically
like if it's just uniqlo here uniqlo and
like a few other places here but in in
england you just have a lot of choices
and there is like no equivalent to
primark i think worldwide there's been
nowhere in the world i've gone to that
is a really really cheap place to find
clothes and just looks as good as
primark i'm just i'm i'm i don't know i
think i will happily still shop at
primark now i i think i think primark
clothes are like underrated just because
it's cheap but you look at primark
clothes and you could easily sell that
for like i just always walk out with
like five t-shirts i'm never gonna wear
because i thought they looked good in
the store
because it's so cheap because you're
like i'll have fun and that's literally
me at unicorn it's it's it's literally
like the primark is the equivalent of
going to an all you can eat buffet
at a restaurant right you're just like
maybe i feel like having an indian curry
and a pizza at the same time
but it's just like you do it because
just like well i just got so much choice
i just maybe i'll have a bit of mexican
as well and a bit of chinese and he just
and it's just an absolute [ __ ] mess
or flight response is kicking and just
hearing that and then you [ __ ] yourself
violently and then you wipe it away with
magic you know i'll i'll i'll oh i'll
look fine bring it back you can have it
yeah sure drip yeah
wait so are you saying primark is drip
i'm not saying you're saying pro mark is
dripping okay i said i'm saying primark
is affordable drip it it doesn't it
doesn't look that's an oxymoron
why why i don't know like
what is drip
expensive clothes just drip is like i
thought it was just clothes that looked
good you know yeah but it's kind of like
the hypebeast stuff as well yeah yeah
there's really expensive oh [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off drip that that just means that
good drip you know you have to buy
brand's name ship for good kind of
usually that's yeah that's what's kind
of been it's kind of been developed a
bit more now and kind of hijacked to be
more of just good clothes yeah just
fashionable clothing just fashionable
clothing that's what i that's what when
i heard drip that's what i always
thought it was you know sometimes brand
name clothes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's what someone who
doesn't wear dreams
are you telling me that every brand name
stuff looks good there are equally as
many brand name stuff that i'm just like
this looks like absolute dog turd and if
you if i see if i see someone wearing
that i'm gonna think they have zero drip
you can wear a louis that could be louis
vuitton and
i get that but like at the same time you
know if i was like walking down the
strip floating off my drip right and
then someone came up to me i was like
damn that drip's sick where'd you get
that i wouldn't like be like primark
like yeah
i'll [ __ ] say that if it looks good
who the [ __ ] gives a [ __ ] if it looks
like if you look like you have drip then
you have drip
i can't matter where it comes from
doesn't matter doesn't matter that's
where it comes from
is like the biggest the biggest [ __ ]
scam there is are you saying to me i
don't know i just wanna i just wanna say
i don't feel bad about buying now i just
want something that lasts as well i'm
obviously not gonna like you know
[ __ ] go to every high-end place and
buy like a you know 500 old t-shirts so
many t-shirts from primark that i sweat
in once and it is like permanently
stained i cannot get those orange pits
out to save my life yeah i mean that's
why you buy five of them right well
that's the problem is i feel bad about
buying a shirt that i've been
immediately yeah after i have one bad
summer
i mean i mean the the fabric is like
definitely low quality
i don't want to buy a shirt that i feel
like i can only get two three good wears
out of exactly well that that's what you
pay for when you pay for cheap fabrics
but that's what i'm saying like why
don't you use that money to just buy one
good quality one i'm gonna ask you and
it's more i'm not i'm not
[ __ ] those little kids making those
shirts you got dripped
i mean you've just been brainwashed by
the fashion industry to say this looks
good because it's expensive
i always think that you pay for the
quality material that lasts a while yeah
i agree
the quality material doesn't always
equate
we buy those glam shirts right they're
like they're like 60 bucks a t-shirt
sometimes like i've got some serious
mileage out there yeah no sorry i i'm
not i like it gladly if people that
shit's drippy yeah dude if people are
like bro oh it's dollars a t-shirt bro
how many of those t-shirts have you
bought from like primark and [ __ ] that
like that are [ __ ] garbage you have
to like i'm i'm not arguing that but i'm
i'm arguing that you can buy good
quality good-looking stuff for a lot
cheaper than you can get for glam and
everything like that i just think fast
fashion is like bad for the environment
it's just bad in general i just think
you should buy shirts that just buy
something that lasts
you saying that
i mean you saying that a t-shirt should
always be like thirty dollars minimum
thirty fifty
dollars not so much about the price for
me it's about like what it's made of
right and like
t-shirts that i don't wear because i
just have too many t-shirts because a
lot of them i would just buy because
they were cheap yeah i would never end
up wearing them i would always wear the
nicer shirts that i could clean didn't
you also say that you just you don't
wash jeans you just throw them away and
buy it
i would wear a pair of jeans for like
two years until they are [ __ ] i would
buy the same pair of jeans over and over
again well you don't wash your jeans i
would i would rarely wash them
you don't need to wash jesus why are we
talking about drip again
you don't need you're taking drip advice
from this guy
from a guy who doesn't wash his jeans
i'm sorry who is the peasant here connor
i'm sorry who is the [ __ ] peasant
here look look i will argue right that
yes like you could buy a 10 shirt right
from primark or something and you can
you know you can layer with something
you know of cheap and you can make it
look good well what i'm saying is the
average
you should never wash a pair of jeans is
one of the ceo of a gene company says
[Music]
the ceo of a gene continually if it's a
good quality said
if
michael
a good quality gene you don't need to
wash it
i will spot wash that [ __ ] you got a
stain just get rid of the stain
i i i do not know enough about this
topic should you get it genuinely you
don't need to be fair i don't
get that [ __ ] out of my face they smell
fresh that's that musky [ __ ] no i've
been sweating in these they smell good
that is drip that's dripping with your
[ __ ] sweat connor is that what you're
talking about what do you mean drip
there's some stains here and then i just
got a spot cleaning gun you don't know
how many people would pay for that
experience
small connor's jeans
get the [ __ ] out of my face man all
those jeans smell it smells good yeah
yeah man give them a wife
i just would you say that after wearing
it in the summer i don't like washing my
jeans because
and frankly as well i don't like how
they feel after you do wash them they
feel horrible the first time you wear
them after you wash jeans they feel all
like crinkly and you got to wear them
back in again i don't like that well i
mean that's if you do like a cold wash
though no no warm water if you do a warm
wash where it doesn't like shrink then
it's fine no it still does it really oh
you're buying the cheap jeans now i'm
just no no i'm not
the uniqlo's finest
[Music]
i mean to be fair unicorn does do good
jeans i'm just saying you don't you
don't wash jeans
i mean
i i just i wear the same pair of jeans
like i don't have multiple i only have
one pair of jeans when it breaks i just
buy a new one when it gets holes buy a
new one when the stains are too deep i
get a new one that's pretty much all i
do if you're considered like you know
like removing the color from like you
know from your shirts i want my jeans to
look fresh
just soft wash everything yeah
you don't need to wash jeans
well there you go i mean the drip king
has spoken you don't need to you don't
need to wash jeans apparently i mean i
just i just think i just think i just
think fashion is [ __ ] don't worry
about how much you spend i mean it's
glad to know that you have trash taste
gone i mean i mean like okay like i the
one thing i never got for example was
supreme right like okay
that's different that's a different
caliber that's what you mean that's a
different character because that's all
comes out it all comes down to drip
right no no like supreme how is it
literally a brand's name
that's expensive as [ __ ] no that's no
that's not a brand it's that's a meme
yeah that's a man
yeah this is not this is not a company
that is is in the business of making
extremely high quality stuff it's in the
business of making scarce stuff
to this point
at this point it is a meme but it wasn't
always a meme if you go you go to any
asian country back when it was like in
their prime and people had supreme on
just because it was expensive and it was
a one of the biggest brand names it
wasn't like good quality
that was it wasn't good cause supreme
was escaped supreme isn't like a daily
wear like skate skateboarders used to
wear that that was like made for
skateboarding yeah but for the longest
time that was drip that was drip right
no you can't you can't argue with me you
gotta go there hasn't been a single like
it might have been there hasn't been a
single piece of supreme shirts or
anything like that philly the old
definition of drip was brend was brand
new yeah it was like gucci louis vuitton
all that kind of yeah
but i feel like now because it's been
adopted so much and used so much over
the past few months it does just mean
looking good yeah and i'm just saying
you don't need to [ __ ] buy expensive
stuff or brand no you don't have a drip
you also shouldn't be buying 10 t-shirts
for five years you also shouldn't you
also shouldn't be wearing a primark
shirt and calling it drip yeah
i i i think you can call it drip i'm
just saying if if if you lay everything
right if you if you layer it right if
you layer right but i'm not there isn't
a single person going to primark and
being like time to buy some dress
no one goes to primark thinking that
also if you spend 30 dollars t-shirt
right
i think that's a worthwhile investment
you're wearing this [ __ ] every day yeah
you know you're like if it looks good
that 30 t-shirt is gonna last you longer
than those three ten pounds yeah
probably like i'm not saying don't buy
30 t-shirts if it looks all i'm saying
is if it looks good it looks good
doesn't matter about the price doesn't
matter about the [ __ ] brand name like
like it's it's it's all a [ __ ] scam
anyway because i think at that point it
literally just comes to like that
person's personal preference of like do
they consider this drip or noise
i'm just saying just
[ __ ] dumb i think we're already
[ __ ] dumb like
what what the [ __ ] does that happen
here's my mouth
like three people have no idea in
fashion being like what is drip i feel
like i'm arguing the best way to perform
open-heart surgery i feel like i'm
really not qualified to be discussing
this obviously
but when are we ever qualified to talk
about we're never qualified to talk
about it so we argue about it
three weeks discuss trip we are like
possibly the three least qualified
people to talk about the trip but that
doesn't mean i'm not going to holly for
it that's trash taste yeah you know who
do has troop though our patrons no they
do they do because they are dripping the
funds into the future man this guy is
dripping man he probably owns ten
supreme court look at look at these
hypebeasts right here look at all of
them amazing hey if you'd like to join
the hypebeast gang aka our patreon then
go to our patreon patreon.com also
follow us on twitter send us your memes
on the subreddit and if you hate our
face listen to us on spotify but uh yeah
what the [ __ ] was this episode even
about i don't know very long absolutely
we've been recording we talked about
scams [ __ ] [ __ ] we talked about scams
harry potter shits and drip
and toy story toy story and we somehow
talked about ava as well
we forgot that we just talked about it
shinji is bojang hortons
bojack uh shit's disappearing harry
potter and he can buy drip from primark
that's three things you should take out
fists
hagrid fists all right
bye guys bye
[Music]
you